this is Jocko podcast number 379 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening so
believe it or not a little over four
years ago we did
a podcast actually we did two podcasts
from a book called psychology for the
fighting man this was a book that was
written in
1943.
subtitle the book is what you should
know about yourself and others
we we did five hours on that book
do we broke it into two podcasts it's
number 164 and 165 if you if you haven't
listened to those two podcasts a ton of
good information in there well that book
like I said was written in 1943.
a couple years after that
the military released another book it
was in 1945. is it after World War II
had ended and this book was called
psychology for the armed services and
there was a lot of information in it
that was very similar that is very
similar between the two books but there
are some highlights
that were changed
you know as they wrapped up two more
years of war in World War II
and I wanted to cover just some
highlights of that from this book
um this book called psychology for the
armed services
so there you go we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna jump into it psychology for
the armed services it starts off in the
preface saying psychology has never had
proper emphasis in American Military
development training and combat
psychology is the science that asks what
man is living breathing man why and how
he does all that he does hence there is
no human activity and therefore no
military activity that does not come
within range of its investigation and of
the application of its principles
psychology as the study of man has
extensive application in every military
field
so there you go
this is usable
just about everywhere
it says one reason that for this failure
is that the scope of psychology has not
been clearly understood this perhaps has
not been entirely the fault of the
services psychologists like military men
have had to create and use a technical
language and like military men they have
become fearful of inaccuracy and
misinterpretation of their special terms
and turns of speech are departed from in
any great degree
in any science this attitude contributes
to an underestimation of the need for
keeping those men who do not speak the
language of the science aware of
developments within it okay so cool
here's what I want to talk about that
I have a
a reference that I make a lot about
people speaking Latin so if there's
something that I don't understand for
instance I don't understand
how to program a computer
so when someone knows how to program a
computer
they speak Latin I don't when someone
knows how to
edit videos they know how to speak Latin
I don't the reason I bring this up is
because
back in the day
when the Bible was out it was written in
Latin
and so therefore the people that spoke
translated the Bible for the other
people and they could say it said
whatever they wanted it to say the
reason people get caught up in this when
I was a radio man in the SEAL Teams
radios propagation programming of radios
the the cryptological material all
those things were Latin to other people
that weren't me
that means when someone said hey can we
get this thing programmed I could say
yeah sure we can do it or I could say
that's not possible I could literally
say those two things so when you're in a
leadership position and you don't speak
whatever language it is you better have
some good relationships and you should
hopefully investigate that language well
enough that you can understand the broad
Concepts you can tell if something
is true or not so if I say Echo can you
do this in the video gay Echo can you
make the can you make this can of go
take off like a rocket
now if you think that's a dumb idea you
could say ah no actually we can't do
that and I just have to shrug my
soldiers and say okay yeah so
if you think it's a cool idea you're
like oh yeah no problem so you speak
Latin I don't you can interpret the
Bible I can't you can tell me what the
Bible says
that's how you end up with a Spanish
Inquisition right like people getting
tortured to death
so be careful and that's what they're
basically saying here is that the
psychologists are get scared of who's
going to understand is it going to be
misinterpreted so they just lie they
just don't say anything yeah which is a
problem yeah and and it's
this might be a broader like way to look
at it but the same exact thing where
yeah if they speak Latin they have the
kind of the luxury or the power
to basically look out for their own
interests right so if you're like um
like your example of me making a video I
think it's dumb right that's my interest
like dumb shouldn't be done right it can
be done now I can just make it look like
it can't be done that's my interest for
it not to be done right that's my
interest so that like um you mentioned
the you said programming a computer
which I'm not sure if there's such thing
as programming I'm sure there is but
it's like let's say coding a website or
something like this right we'll see okay
Latin speaker
anyway the bro but when I was a kid yeah
it was called computer programming okay
so you wanna go back to the 80s with the
TRS-80 and the Commodore vic-20 that was
called computer programming so you want
to call it coding now you want to step
up there call me a boomer yeah no no got
it you're actually right there of course
there is computer programming for sure
but nonetheless let's say a website it's
more appropriate for this particular
example in my opinion given what I know
which is not much but either way so
website uh program let's say you're um
working for you I'm program I'm building
a website for you and you're like hey I
need this feature I wanted to do this
now I know how making that I know the
process to that
so I can be like hey I can't do or that
can't be done you know that's like oh
that involves technology that doesn't
exist or something like this or I could
be like hey that's like of course I
could do that but hey just bear with me
this is going to be a lot of work and
it's gonna be expensive and kind of
costly but worth it and all this stuff
meanwhile like all I got to do is
freaking good coffee nowadays local chat
GPT and be like oh here's my code you
know 29 seconds and done and I'm like
hey that's like and I'll slow roll it
you know whatever that's me speaking big
dollars
yeah so I can look out for my own
interest meanwhile you're blind to it
they say that you know the old uh the
classic uh the mechanic thing yeah you
bring your car to the mechanic the flux
capacitors bro that's gonna cost about 2
800 bucks yeah we can get it done for
you hopefully bruh they take a while
they're so the ones that are because
there's very varying levels of this
right in the mechanic shop right where
they um the good ones are not good the
bad one the devious ones they'll scare
you into it they'll be like hey you can
let it go oh no you can let it go yeah
yeah but I just wouldn't put your family
in the car yeah exactly right it's like
I would just you know you could let it
go but you just never know with these
things I'd hate to see you know to have
you driving down the freeway and this
thing go out on you you know at 75 miles
per hour like that kind of stuff you
know and I say bring it
yeah what is true yeah so that's the
idea what they what they were worried
about the psychologists sometimes they
they want to keep another little little
job security too right yeah like I can
analyze what's making this person tick
but why would I tell you then you don't
have me as the expert what if you could
just say hey Jaco if you want your
website do that you could just click on
this thing over here and open this menu
and click you know open or whatever yeah
but instead you're like oh I can do it
for you yeah like uh like Facebook right
you get on Facebook like hey Echo I'd
really like to change my profile picture
yeah you could be like okay you know
what why don't you send me a picture
that you like and I'll try and get it
uploaded in the next few days yeah you
could just tell me hey there's a screen
on the a menu on the lower right click
upload file and you can do it but you
don't want to tell me that you want that
job security all day yeah
so there you go all right uh um they got
some reasons why this happened one of
the reasons the psychology has not been
fostered within the armed services
between the great Wars has been lack of
books through which the military man
might gain a clear idea of the manner in
which principles of psychology apply to
everything he does they just got some
reasons and then they talk about that
book that I talked about earlier
uh not until 1943 was any any book
written which endeavored to outline
ordinary in ordinary language what the
whole body of psychological knowledge
held for the military man and by the way
when I'm talking about the military man
I'm talking about men women people human
beings
yes they're putting it into a military
context but the reason that we talk
about these things is because it
transfers into all aspects of business
and life
this book was psychology for the
Fighting Man of which several hundred
thousand copies have been used in the
armed services such a book would have
been of Great Value throughout the years
of Peace but it was a development that
did not come until War had reawakened
military men to the need for it and
psychologists to the desirability of
helping with such a project
so
again we covered that book on podcast
164 165 and then it talks about this
book and this book is going to make you
a little bit nervous
because it's it's going to basically say
we're writing in Latin listen to this
the present book which is the book we're
covering today psychology for the armed
services arose from the first book which
contained a minimum of technical
explanation psychology for the armed
services is intended as a textbook
written on the college level but also a
book in which the military and Naval
applications of psychological principles
and the base principles themselves are
more fully developed than in the earlier
walk but in in the earlier work now I
have both these books
they're actually not as different as
this homeboy makes it out to sound this
guy Joseph I green who's a colonel in
the Infantry send it infantry but
and as I looked through to find some of
the differences there was a lot there
was more similarities way more
similarities than there was differences
uh some of the the topics covered in
this book in this in this book that
we're talking about right now which is
called the psychology for the armed
services the book that we're covering
right now
here's the contents of it there's uh the
use of psychology in war there's the I
as a military instrument I was thinking
let me get that to huberman he'll be
interested in that it goes in I mean
there's
40 or 50 pages I guess 40 pages of the I
as a military instrument the eye as a
camera visual Acuity glare visual
fatigue on all these things visual
adaption and night vision
color and camouflage all that stuff is
about sight so it's literally talking
about these things and we covered some
of those in in the first podcast we're
not going to cover them today then it
goes into the ear as a military
instrument the nature of hearing this
the physiology of hearing then it goes
to smell in war again this is kind of
this probably you weren't predicting
these right no
equilibrium and bodily orientation
topographical orientation let's talk
about how your mind works to remember
maps and mental map making and things
like that efficiency and fatigue again
we covered a bunch of these already and
they're not that much different in this
book in fact I would venture to say the
other book is the book psychology for
the mighty for the fighting man which is
written in a little less Latin and a
little more English
is a little better
efficiency and fatigue physical
conditions of efficiency there's a whole
section here called the selection of men
and again we covered on the first one
this one doesn't differ that much use
more technical terms but those are on
podcast 164 165 learning talks about how
we learn how to teach Army teaching
motivation mrl again these are all
things that were covered in English
more vernacular common vernacular in the
book psychology for the Fighting Man
personal adjustment
fear
and anger there's a section here about
emotion now we are going to touch on
that one
because that one is a little bit there's
some some important points that I wanted
to either rehash or show the differences
between there's a thing about sex
which I was kind of like how does that
fit in and then you start reading it's
like oh you've got
three thousand five thousand or ten
thousand men with no women around what
is that doing to their brains yeah
well it's gonna have an impact
it's got leadership and we are
definitely going to touch on leadership
that's the main reason why I decided hey
you know what we do need to hit this
book
because the leadership section
and then it closes out with rumor and
and panic and mobs and assessing opinion
and discovering facts and propaganda and
psychological warfare the main things
that we're gonna focus on is
the the fear and emotions and Leadership
because I think those are the the things
that actually lent some more information
that was usable compared to what we
covered on the first two podcasts four
years ago when we covered those podcasts
the use of psychology in War chapter one
war is fought by men
modern war is fought by men and machines
a great variety of machines but also a
great variety of men with various skills
and abilities without men the machines
are useless without the special skills
and abilities of men for operating the
machines
and for performing all the other complex
operations of war the armed forces would
be helpless in other words the Army and
Navy in a very serious and specific
manner have to take account of human
nature
so no matter what you're doing
you have to account for Human Nature
and we you get into a situation where
you've got a bunch of machines but you
don't have people that can operate those
machines and you don't account for what
that does to them
and how that machine impacts them
you're gonna end up in a situation where
things don't go the way you want them to
go so we have to understand the
psychology we have to understand human
nature it goes on in a way a man is
himself a machine
that is to say he is a complex organism
with certain properties capacities and
abilities some of his abilities as well
as some of his deficiencies he has
inherited
for instance no man can see as well in
the dark as in daylight and every man
who sees at all can see better at night
after he has remained sometime in the
dark
this human ability and limitation this
property of seeing of the seeing eye is
inherited
training Alters the capacity only a
little
there are however great differences in
sensitivity among men
some have much better night vision than
others and should therefore be the ones
selected for making observations at
night the military problem here is first
to know the capacities and limitation of
the human eye and then to adjust the
military requirements to them so as to
employ the maximal visual Acuity without
demanding The Impossible
and this is one example that they're
giving
some people can see better than others
Chuck Yeager
unbelievable eyesight
makes a great fighter pilot you have
something that can't see very well you
don't want him to be a fighter pilot
Dave Burke good deal Thief excellent
eyesight less important nowadays because
you got radar yeah
but back in the day you want that
eyesight
yeah
it goes on most human skills are however
not inherited but learned
that is true of all complex skills men
differ in their aptitudes for learning
for learning in general and also for
learning particular skills this is
someone who's asking me about skydiving
the other day
and
they they were like you know why would
someone not be a good skydiver yeah well
basically I think most humans can get to
a point where they're they can do it
right they can do it that was me you're
talking to by the way oh okay
some people
are gonna learn it quicker than others
yeah
it's like surfing there's some people
you take their first day out surfing
they've never surfed before
and they can stand up their first day
they will stand up on this bird and ride
a wave on their first day some people
aren't going to be able to stand up on a
board for four or five days almost
everyone after four or five days is
gonna be able to stand up and ride a
wave to the beach yeah
I don't know why that is it's like in
basic SEAL training
there's going to be some things
let's say
when you're out on San Clemente Island
you're going through the land Warfare
block of training
you've gotta shoot a certain
qualification with a rifle you gotta
shoot a certain score on targets with a
pistol and rifle yeah
out of every hundred guys that go out
there
there's going to be one of them that
just like doesn't it's gonna take them
another shot like they're gonna get
rolled back out of every hundred maybe
maybe it's three out of every 100 maybe
it's seven I don't know the numbers yeah
I'm sure the buds instructors could tell
you hey it's probably this you know
whatever four percent but there are
going to be some people
just don't they're not going to be good
at it
and they very few people will actually
get dropped from training because they
couldn't fire a pistol and a rifle and
get the required score after two classes
I would say that number's got to be
absolutely tiny um
but there are going to be some people
that are going to basically take longer
to learn yeah same thing with
parachuting same thing with something
more complex like Close Quarters combat
yeah look there's a certain standard you
have to get to when you're going through
that what's now called sqt Co
qualification you got to get a certain
level
you can't make mistakes you can only
make you know three mistakes or whatever
the number is they have a way of grading
it more people there's probably
seven people out of a hundred that are
or three people out of I don't know what
the number is but what I'm trying to say
is there's some people it's going to
take them longer to learn it
occasionally someone's not going to be
able to learn it
occasionally someone's not gonna be able
to learn it so we have to take that into
account and that's exactly what they're
saying here
is that you've got to and it goes into
here we take into account two factors
the different skills that men already
have Acquired and the different
capacities they have for acquiring a
particular a particular skill quickly
because there's some people that they
were already parachute qualified like
they were a Free Fall Guy they're not
gonna have any trouble now they might
not they might have been not a naturally
gifted free follower but they've got 280
jumps when they show up to buds yeah
they're gonna get free they're gonna be
no problem for them they've already done
it before
yeah I remember when I asked that
because parachuting Free Fall skydiving
that stuff is like since that's real
foreign to me flying through the air and
being good at it
and then maneuvering like any kind of
parachute equipment and that that's not
obvious what kind of traits you need to
have or not have
to be good at that I don't even know
what good looks like I know what bad
looks but I I don't even so it's like oh
what makes you good you know whatever
like you know in in certain other
like surfing for example you get a kid
who has good balance because you you can
see kids right like this kid has good
balance this kid the Heritage ability of
balance right yeah exactly we're talking
about yeah it's real obvious even if you
don't surf you're like okay if you have
good balance that's going to help you in
surfing or you know snowboarding you
know this case may or may not be
um but skydiving is like bro you don't
need balance well not not in when you
look at someone skydiving it doesn't
intuitively hit you like oh you need
balance for that even though you
probably I don't know I'm assuming you
probably do need I'm kind of no you
don't need balance oh yeah there's this
that's what makes skydiving a weird
example yeah because there's this I
think it's proprioception and then very
rapid learning because you have to learn
that oh when I move my arm like this it
makes me go over there when I move my
other arm like this makes me go over
there so you're learning very rapidly
how your body is reacting to what your
body is doing yeah and therefore if you
have that ability to do that you'll get
good at it quickly yeah if you don't
it's a weird there's a weird instinct
when it comes to Free Falling
and that is if in a way your brain can
think yours your brain can think you're
in the water yeah because there's no
there's no other thing to compare it to
and when you're in water you're kind of
weightless but if you want to move over
there you kind of move that and so you
see guys skydiving they they swim yeah
they like try and swim through the air
but it doesn't work that way at all
that's crazy so yeah
I think it has to do with proprioception
and then it has to do with being able to
rapidly learn what your body is doing
what the reaction is and then making
adjustments yes and you know what I
think I think I don't know I'm not an
expert but what I think is rapidly learn
and at the same time probably equally as
important almost it's a version of
unlearning too so like you you mentioned
like um skydiving and swimming right
most people if they know how to swim it
seems natural they it's almost like a
language Right Where You Gotta like
unlearn that language it doesn't mean
this anymore so like you're
in the pool or in the ocean or when
you're swimming when you do this thing
yeah it it has this result and it's
automatic already right in your brain
you got to unlearn that in the air right
it's just like um
so snowboarding whatever
if you're not used to it this is my
experience in the beginning when you're
not used to it and you're like you kind
of go into sort of panic mode which is
that's when you go to your Natural
Instincts you you want to lean back and
whatever I'm going too fast I want to
lean back you know that's just the thing
but leaning back gives you less control
you can't turn it's like it's basically
the exact opposite of what you want to
do to control your your speed your turn
whatever but so you got to unlearn that
and it's hard to unlearn for certain
people when they're so when they learned
it so I don't know what the word would
be like hardcore they learned it so hard
it's so ingrained in them it's harder to
unlearn that kind of stuff yeah so it's
harder to learn the new stuff you got to
learn and different people will be at
different capacities across the spectrum
of what we're talking about some people
they feel that almost immediately like
oh I gotta Lean Forward yeah and all of
a sudden they're good to go yeah some
people they just can't they have a
different capacity for Learning and by
the way that capacity for learning in
this particular case has nothing to do
with your intellectual capacity because
they're smart people that are sky trash
when it comes to skydiving right or
they're they're terrible doing CQC
they're the smartest person with the
highest ASVAB score meaning they have
the highest capacity for intellectual
learning and they're a train wreck in
the house or they're a train wreck in
the sky like this happens so there's
this
there's this and it talks about this I
don't know how much we're going to cover
this but in the selection of men in the
other book in Psychology for fighting
man it's like you could take the the
most
let's say the person with the highest
intellectual capacity and he's going to
be terrible at some jobs for instance
jobs that don't require a lot of
intellectual thought they're going to
get bored they're not going to care
they're going to look for shortcuts like
that's a real problem and then you take
someone that doesn't have a high
intellectual capacity they might be good
at this particular job but you put them
in the job that requires a high
intellectual capacity and they're gonna
have problems yeah that's such a like
genius yet simple way to put it which to
be honestly never really thought of in
these exact terms where
if you're good at something whether it
be like anything requiring intellectual
ability smart whatever the word is
whatever the quality is if you put them
in a job that doesn't require that they
might not be that good yeah
yeah so it's one of the it's actually a
fallacy it's a cognitive bias I forget
what it you actually mentioned in a few
few weeks ago uh it's where it's I think
it's a form of anchoring or no no it's
like the halo effect I think halo effect
where yeah we're like they're good at
this yeah this guy is a Princeton
master's degree you know whatever so of
course he's going to be good at
everything when it's like that's not
true he's good at getting Princeton
degrees in that subject you know and
what's really crazy is you take a you
take a guy that went to an Ivy League
school who had a perfect SAT score and
you put him in a seal platoon he doesn't
know how to interact with other people
he doesn't have good emotional IQ right
and so he's a disaster you know there
was a while when they were recruiting a
bunch of these ivy league guys for the
SEAL Teams this was in the 90s and they
realized after a little while we're not
getting what we want we're getting some
of what we want some of the guys are
fantastic we have some ivy league
officers that were great officers we
also had some ivy league officers that
were disasters and they realized they
were looking for the wrong thing yeah
they were looking for oh we'll just
grade them halo effect oh this person
went to Harvard and got a great SAT
score they must be smart they're going
to be a great seal platoon leader nope
doesn't work that way sorry and and look
they can be great yeah but it's not it's
not necessarily and there's a decent
chance that they're not good
so you got to pay attention to these
things this is the this is the use of
psychology and War and life
uh goes on here to say since you cannot
create new men for war you have to adapt
the men already available
thus it comes down
it does comes about that the great task
of creating new forces is principally a
matter of selection and training it is
necessary to choose men who already have
the needed skill or else to train them
actually the Armed Forces do both if
it's if it's a civilian skill like
typewriting is also a military skill men
already have that ability types can
easily be selected if there's not enough
you could train them that's basically
what it says there
um
then it says oh it's basically this is
what we were just talking about for
training there are differences of
aptitude among men a mentally deficient
man although perhaps bright enough for a
number of tasks necessary in the armed
forces could never learn code fast
enough to make training him worthwhile
many bright men moreover lack code
aptitude and should not be trained when
more apt men are available
psychological tests can determine what
capacity a man has for learning a wide
variety of tasks for learning code in
particular selection and training go
hand in hand
um this is
I I think this yeah this is talking
about Morse code now I had to learn
Morse code and again what's interesting
about learning Morse code
was we had to learn to send and receive
Morse code and I forget the numbers but
there was a qualification we had to get
in order to pass the radium in school
that I went to for being a seal radiomon
RTO
and some guys do they freaking
struggled they struggled with it
so I think everyone ended up passing but
some guys barely passed I think they got
a little extra love from the freaking
chief that was running the course like
all right dude you're close enough if we
have a thermonuclear war and the only
way to transmit communication is through
HF Morris code
you're gonna die but other than that
you'll be all right but it's interesting
it hadn't it in some of the guys were
just like like there was no one that was
some brilliant guy that oh this is easy
some of the smart guys had a hard time
some of the guys that were kind of rocks
were like oh this is easy you know what
I'm saying like they just happen to have
it's like tonal languages do you know
what those are
yes
um like in actually I was gonna say like
pretty much any
language scenario like if you have
exposure to let's say three different
languages you don't necessarily have to
talk them but you have exposure to them
constantly or whatever the probability
of you picking up like another language
even they can be along those same lines
just to a small degree you're going to
pick it up way better than the smartest
of guys well I mean not every single
time but for the most part the smartest
of guys
who has very little or no exposure to
other languages yeah you know yeah
totally the tonal language is are you
hear the differences I I would love to
give you a great example I I think one
of them is like the word
how in Thai and it's a cow cow cow
and and they might sound the same to an
American that speaks English
but for them one means rice one means
white one means eat like they'll mean
different things and some guys GIF GIF
went to Thai language school oh yeah or
do you go to Tire Vietnamese he might
have gone to Vietnamese but he went to a
tonal language school he said some
people just like they just can't hear it
oh they just could not hear it so we in
sixth grade I took Mandarin Chinese
[Music]
and that was the deal I was like a lot
of these words are the same words
technically but like the way and it was
the actual Chinese lady so she was she
that was her first language so I was
like I am not going to be able to learn
this plus I was in sixth grade so you
know so it's different than like Spanish
so Hawaiian
Japanese
um Filipino these are like the cultures
that are in Hawaii right so you get
different accents and then not to
mention pigeon which is like that's an
accent so Spanish easy like if you
technically if you really want a good
like uh
how should they scaffolding for Spanish
it's basically pigeon with a rolled R
that's it if you do a Spanish or like a
Spanish accent and take off the R's at
the end and you replace them with a like
ah
um you got pigeon straight up and I'll
tell it's a funny example of this where
you ever watch you ever heard uh or seen
the movie 50 First Dates no I've seen
that okay so it's Adam Sandler this
sounds like a romantic comedy yeah okay
yeah therefore it's not your jam
but Rob Schneider okay you know Great
American actor
um he uh he played I forget his name on
there but he played a full-on uh local
Hawaiian guy right so he had to do a
pigeon accent and he'd mess it up
because he'd include the RS and it just
sounds like a Spanish accent but all you
gotta is take off the r at the end make
it into a boom you got pigeon it's easy
to recognize when you you're you hear
pigeon you hear Filipino accents you
hear like all these different accents
and you're like oh I see that one you
know it's like way more recognizable so
it'll come way more natural but some
people have a natural ability what now
whether that's natural because they were
round languages when they were little I
don't know yeah but by the time they're
ready to be trained some of them have
that ability some of them don't and
that's the way it is and if you try and
take someone that can't hear those
different tones and you try and make
them learn Mandarin Chinese it ain't
gonna happen it ain't gonna happen
so that's what they're saying in here
um and they actually just say this it
does not matter whether aptitudes are
inherited or learned you have to take
them as you find them a learned civilian
skill can often constitutes an aptitude
for learning a military skill for
instance civilian truck drivers have an
aptitude for driving army trucks still
need to much further training pretty
straightforward what what's interesting
about this is
this is a little bit counter to the idea
the modern idea that you can do whatever
you want Echo Charles like oh you can do
anything Echo like your parents oh Echo
you can do anything hey man actually you
can't learn Mandarin right because you
can't hear tone so you can but it's
going to be a huge effort you're not
never gonna be very good at it because
there's some people that learn a
language but damn dude like it is hard
and they don't sound they still sound
like a gringo like no matter what so
that's a reality that a lot of times
people don't want to face like hey you
just don't really have the capacity for
this thing and you shouldn't really be
doing this right and you better hope
that what you want to do
lines up with what you can do you know
like
Dave Burke good deal yeah
obviously he wanted to be a fighter
pilot yeah and he's a humble guy but he
also quite obviously had a natural a
bill he had he to be to to have achieved
the level of pilot that he did he
clearly had some level of natural
ability we know he had great eyesight
but and the weird thing is he wasn't
like he didn't play baseball he didn't
have some big hand-eye coordination he
had a natural
gift at some level to be able to fly as
good as he could fly some feeling for
that something that you get when you
move that plane around you understand it
you're connected to it where some people
aren't yeah and look and he also got
maximum training you know being a top
gun fighter pilot and Top Gun instructor
and all those things
but he had to have some natural level to
be able to make that stuff happen
and thankfully for him luckily for him
those things lined up you know if he was
like oh I really want to be a mandarin
you know linguist there's a chance he
couldn't have done that he might have
been like oh I want to be a what's
another job in the military oh here's
one I want to be EOD he might have been
colorblind and if you're colorblind you
can't be EOD like that's just a
disqualifier oh yeah so he you gotta you
gotta hope that you are lucky enough
that what you want to do is what you can
do but also you got to be
Savvy enough to say you know what I want
to do that but I can't do it you know I
want to do that but I actually can't do
it so I need to find something else to
do yeah
um
that says these problems concerning
human abilities and aptitudes are
psychological often not always it is the
psychologist who can help Armed Forces
find out what human abilities are needed
and how to acquire them by selection of
training psychology is the study of
human nature and Wars are fought by
human beings
so there you go it goes on to say
psychological military problems also
include the study
of the other persons with whom the armed
forces have to deal the civilians on the
home front who support the armed forces
the civilians have occupied country who
come in contact with Soldiers and
Sailors the enemy civilians and the
enemy and Soldiers and Sailors
military men must know about the habits
and thought of thought and action of all
these kinds of people they're often
concerned with their beliefs their
emotions their
prospective actions
the leaders use various means for
assessing opinions of such social groups
and then knowing how these groups are
thinking and feeling
they may try to alter their opinions
using psychological warfare there's all
kinds of things that are
psychological or psychology is used for
in war
as a matter as a practical matter the
psychological business of the Army and
the Navy with which this book is
concerned breaks down in the following
Seven Fields observation performance
selection training personal adjustment
social relations opinion and propaganda
and so like I said that a lot of these
we covered on podcast 164 and 165 but
there was some interesting excerpts that
are a little bit different one of those
sections is about emotion and
specifically here we're going to talk
about fear
because I think there's some a lot to
learn when I reread this section fear is
an unpleasant emotion if intense it
involves presently the whole
psychological the whole physiological
pattern induced by the action of the
sympathetic nervous system it differs
from anger in that it is characterized
by an attempt to withdraw from the scene
or avoid the fearful situation
so that's what fear does this whole
sympathetic nervous system is going to
do things things are going to get
released adrenaline's going to grow all
those things are going to happen
to try and make you avoid the fearful
situation the energy with which the
sympathetic system provides the body in
a fearful emergency is normally used for
escape not for attack
fortunately the energy can nevertheless
be diverted from flight to attack and
thus fear may come to have a military
use
so you it may feel fear and you can
change that fear from making you want to
run you can utilize that energy
you can utilize anger you can even
utilize frustration you can actually
utilize these emotions as long as you
control your emotions as long as you
understand what's happening
it says fear thrives on frustration it
persists and grows when danger impends
especially if there's nothing the
fearful man can do to lessen the threat
against him
action on the other hand always lessens
or may even abolish fear resolving the
frustration and eliminating it now this
is why you get freaking guys in World
War One getting shell shock because
there's nothing you can do about you're
sitting in a trench waiting to die um
like at least when you charge your
charging but sitting that's why it's
called shell shock it wasn't called
attack shock because when you're
attacking you feel better when you're
sitting in a trench waiting to die
waiting to have a freaking giant shell
land on your spot and get blown to
Smithereens like all of your friends
have been
and there's nothing you can do about it
um
the soldier who transforms fear into
Escape rushing headlong through the
woods over fencers and across gullies is
usually too busy to feel Afraid Anymore
others will describe him as afraid but
the emotion that started his action the
gnawing haunting sickening dread will
itself very likely be gone it may come
again if he is stopped by an obstacle or
a command being forced to wait inactive
for danger to come to him
so you get that that fear comes up once
it's going once you're taking action
it's kind of gone
people tell you that fear and anger are
sometimes mixed it seems much more
likely that what happens is the fearful
man at Bay turns on his enemy to attack
him just as the fearful animal attacks
when cornered the man who is attacking
whether he be grappling with another man
with his life as the prize salute or
shooting from a foxhole as the enemy
comes across the clearing is working his
sympathetic system for all it is worth
but not any longer feeling very much
afraid he is much too busy that's funny
when we had uh we had Mike Thornton on
and I asked him you know he's running
across to get his
shot platoon leader there's just total
Mayhem going on
Mike Thornton Medal of Honor recipient
Seal Team One
and he came on and gave us a full
debrief I was like oh were you scared
he's like oh that was busy this is
exactly what he says
his mouth may be dry he may feel a lump
in his throat still and a little bit
sick in his stomach but the sympathy the
sympathetic system does that does that
to him but at least you could not say
whether he's afraid or angry chiefly he
is active and moved neither specifically
afraid nor angry fear as distinguished
from anger is often identical with
anxiety that state of depressed
unpleasant fatigued apprehensive worry
which frustration always produces
fatigue always accompanies prolonged
anxiety and also those early stages of
fear before the sympathetic system has
released enough adrenaline into the
blood to abolish it on the other hand
acute Terror suddenly aroused is
something more than anxiety the
terrorized person knows of what he is
afraid and his sympathetic system may be
energized too rapidly for him to feel
fatigue at any rate he will not be in
Terror
he will not in Terror be noticing
fatigue
what he notices usually inhibition
inability to act run or fight so often
Terror immobilizes a man it may of
course mobilize him instead and make him
run and panic
so
it's pretty it's pretty interesting that
that Terror
is going to I mean
uh either frees you up or make you
mobilized we prefer mobilized this is
flight flight or freeze remember yeah I
don't know I remember I used to be fight
or flight and it's someone at some point
someone added freeze yeah
and I've seen guys freeze yeah
I'll see you guys fight
I've seen some flight can get a little
bit crazy the characteristics of fear
are then unpleasantness fatigue and the
desire to escape a state of mind that
ends ordinarily in getting the
sympathetic system to work and sometimes
in vigorous action which replaces the
fear the action of attack or Escape or
of doing something else either about the
danger or about something that is
important a man may forget his fear when
he suddenly has his wounded comrade to
attend to forget fear through his danger
is not those danger is not diminished
so this is again action taking action
I said this on on the huberman when I
was on huberman's podcast you know I was
like oh you're hesitant you're scared
like action is the solution no here you
go
the Army using its excellent
questionnaire method this that's an
exact quote and I don't know if someone
was just kissing ass to the person that
wrote this or whatever but says the Army
using its excellent questionnaire method
has collected from combat troops
a list of fears a list of their felt
symptoms of fear here is what the list
with the frequencies with which the
symptoms were reported the reason I
wanted to go over this is because I
always talk about detaching
and I talk about knowing what your red
flags are meaning how do you know when
you need to detach
and I always talk about hey you start to
raise your voice because you're getting
mad you start to clench your fists
because you're getting mad you start to
get red in the face because you're
getting mad you start to breathe harder
because you're getting mad
so all those things are good to identify
so that you can recognize that you're
starting to lose your temper or get
emotional it says here violent pounding
of the heart 86 percent sickening
sinking feeling in the stomach 75
feeling sick in the stomach 59 trembling
and shaking 56 cold sweat 55 tense
feeling in the stomach 53 feeling of
weakness and faintness 51 vomiting 24
losing control of bowels 10 urinating in
the pants ten percent what is the
percentages represent uh how often
people reported this
or the the frequencies with which the
symptoms were reported so 10 of people
said they pissed their pants ten percent
of people said they their pants 24
of people said they threw up we used to
catch a lot of guys uh like insurgents
or terrorists when we would hit their
houses at two o'clock in the morning
there was I would say there was more
than 10 of people that pissed themselves
maybe but not that much see but it was
pretty normal that a guy should himself
re-piss himself like some mujahideen
fighter you blast their door off their
house they're pissing their pants that's
good it was always kind of nasty to deal
with but that makes yeah
but what's interesting about those is we
got to remember
what are those for you you know next
time you get pissed and you lose your
temper try and reverse engineer it and
figure out what you could have noticed
so that you can stop it next time
um
says here
it says here mostly fear makes sense to
the fearful man because he knows of what
he's afraid he knows not only that he is
afraid but that he has reason to be
afraid sometimes he becomes anxious
however without any assignable cause he
is scared but he does not know
he does not know that he is and this is
something I have talked about a lot
when I would have a fighter in the UFC
and they'd be nervous and they wouldn't
know what it was but they'd feel like
sick and they'd feel like and I said oh
you're that's nerves and it's good
because it's preparing you for combat
if you don't tell them that they
actually think they're sick they think
there's something wrong with them same
thing with combat oh you feel you feel
like a little bit sick you've gone to
the you know you've hit the out you've
hit the uh the porta potty four times in
the last 20 minutes you good
uh yeah and they think they feel sick
but they're really just nervous yeah
they take that combat three times
before they get in their Humvee because
they're nervous as hell and so you go
hey man it's all good that's just your
nerves and that's a good thing I always
tell them it's a positive thing it means
your body's getting ready for combat so
that's good
says here he wants to get out of
fighting while his pride makes him want
to fight so he finds himself frustrated
in conflict in Conflict Too Proud to
admit even to himself his desire to
escape
he goes on about his work depressed
tired feeling sick to his stomach not
knowing the cause of his trouble
actually he's afraid
you do not have to know of what you are
afraid in order to be afraid although
you will seldom tell other persons about
a fear that seems you have no reasonable
cause
it is because action is the cure for
fear that courage and fear so often go
together this is awesome a man is afraid
because he is afraid his sympathetic
nervous system is gearing him to
activity physically he's in good
position to do something about the
danger that haunts him shall it be
Escape or attack discipline Pride
confidence and leaders belief in war
aims and a host of other of other forces
press him on toward bravery thus his
heart in his throat he stumbles into
action finds action good lets out a yell
from his dry mouth and is soon fighting
away vigorously his mouth moist again
and his fatigue gone his fear was useful
he it provided the energy and other
things steered him to the right kind of
activity
boom oh you're scared I'm going on the
attack
when we're uh kids
it was like it was actually a mix
between fear and anger probably some
like frustration where
basically you do that you kind of like
flip the switch when it just turns to
complete aggression right that's like
the the process and we'd call it amping
out so like when you when you use that
Christmas Story yes that was a perfect
example yeah rage so that was like a uh
it's like an expression when we're
little kids like yeah when two people
get into a fight like there's a
difference between two guys getting a
fight and getting mad and talking trash
to each other and all that and then a
guy just amping out like Echo clamped
out
yes he was like and it's a very very
distinct differentiator when a guy amps
out and a guy just gets into a fighting
because when you amp out you're crying
like everything is coming out everything
you're crying you may or may not be
yelling uh you're winning you're yeah
most of the time you're winning you
don't know when to stop like you know
just like on Christmas story where he
was beating that kid down down and they
had to break it up or whatever like
that's amping out so it's like all the
the version the
essentially the
beginner version of taking all that
negative like that fear and all that
stuff and then like directing it and
utilizing it happy now there you go man
this Nick isn't incredible like how
specific this is and yet how totally
accurate it is and how if you understand
it then you can recognize it yourself
and you can recognize it in others yeah
like when you see someone's afraid the
best thing you can do is tell them hey
here's what we're gonna do
unfortunately goes back to the book here
on the other hand fear does not always
disappear in combat perhaps because not
all combat is active or because activity
is not strong enough to banish fear the
Army has questioned combat troops as to
what when they feel the most fear 39 of
men reported fear as the strongest
before battle
35 percent said it was strongest during
battle 16 said it was greatest the
greatest fear came for them after combat
and 10 couldn't decide
have you ever done something when you
got done you're like oh yes that's the
one that seems to stick out in my mind
the most rough comeback from something
and been like
you ever been in because the the time or
one of the times it sticks out the most
to me is I was a white man North Shore
Oahu damn and it was a big day it was a
huge day and I went out whatever
yeah yeah so
um you know I grew up in the water
whatever I'm not one of these visitors
who are intimidated by this kind of
stuff but I went out there I was like oh
yeah it's big it's big on here
and you got to go with the flow where I
was just focusing now I can't catch any
of these ways they're too big and
there's too many of them coming you know
guys are shredding surfing outside
um and then I was like okay I'm going
back in this is not fun you know I'm
like all my attention and energy is
going is going to going under these ways
preparing for the next week yeah it's
like survive but I wasn't scared
necessarily yeah
yeah I was it was more like this is too
much work and it's not fun out here you
know it's like it's not fun so I went in
and as I went in that's when I was like
bro that was scary like I felt the
actual fear afterwards which in a way
when you kind of think about it like
doesn't make that much sense because
you'd think oh yeah when it hits you
that's when it's scary right but I guess
maybe I was too focused on what I was
doing to realize how in danger I
probably was yeah I was I was out
surfing with my son when he was a little
kid it was a big day and we were surfing
the spot where if you get in the wrong
spot you're gonna get slammed into a
cliff and you're gonna have real
problems yeah and normally as long as
you catch waves and you ride you know
you know how you ride yeah you know
across the wave that you ride away from
that area well something happened where
he fell or something like this
and all of a sudden he was in the danger
complete danger zone and I remember I
had just caught a wave and wrote it
correctly and so now I'm I see him I
look back and I see him like
he I didn't see what happened but now he
was in the zone of how old was he at
this time he was probably like nine and
I look at him and I was kind of I just
was thinking to myself this is a test
because he has to get himself out of
here I mean I'm gonna go I mean look if
he starts going in the Rocks I guess
I'll go over there but it's probably
going to be a problem for both of us
then right and I'm just looking at him
going like is does he I was thinking
myself does he know the situation he's
in right now and he just you know he
just looked pretty normal and paddled
back out and made it was a little bit of
a struggle but he got back out yeah you
know and I was kind of like how'd you
get in there
he's definitely when he got out of it he
definitely had recognized it but he
seemed pretty calm in the situation but
I think he after he got out was like
that was sketch yeah yeah that means
that story one time he another funny day
it was a big even bigger day we were in
a different spot
and I caught a wave and and he caught a
wave and and then we were both
trying to get back out and it was
closing out and we were inside again up
against rocks where there's no good
option yeah
and his leech broke on his board
and I saw you know geek and I was
watching him like I came up and I was
looking for him and he came up and I
could see as soon as he came up and he
knew his leash was gone and he was just
like by his own
he was out there and he had a look on
his face like I'm gonna need some help
it was like I I got you can you help
them yeah I did oh yeah for sure because
if I didn't help him it could have been
a problem uh I also dig the hell out of
my board because well his board he was
surfing a foam board this one he's a
little kid you know he used to go out on
a foam board as you heard Josh Hall tell
that story with Josh Hall's like gonna
yell at me because I had a little kid
out there is too dangerous Josh Hall was
gonna come and give me the business and
he paddled over he's like I'm just gonna
let this guy do what he wants
that was my intro to Josh Hall but yeah
it was one of those it was one of those
days a big big big man day like there's
no kids out there barely even men out
there yeah and that's like a you know it
it might sound dramatic to be like hey
because that can be life or death but it
is because you can definitely and you
brought this up a few you see aware you
can't fight waves you can't fight them
you know what's sketchy when you're in
big big waves when you know the water
that's what it's like white water and
you don't get the normal policies it's
just like pulling an air yeah you know
that's what I was thinking about we were
talking about free fall like you're just
going and it doesn't move you anywhere
all right
says here uh let's just I'm gonna go to
this section here so it goes into
Fighting Fear
a great deal can be learned about fear
from a study the rules for overcoming it
here they are action dispels fear it's
the guess is so important that's why
like is your kids caught in the surf
zone you know what you do you go hey
start paddling out hey paddle paddle
South you know like you give them dirty
give them something to do just don't let
them sit there yeah you know you got to
give them something to do
action dispels fear in the suspense
before combat when men are ready for
action and waiting for the signal for
the signal to start fears at its height
it will disappear for many of the men
when actually commence commences a
questionnaire given to several hundred
members of the Abraham Lincoln Brigade
Veterans of the Spanish Civil War
disclosed that 71 percent of these men
experience greater fear before going
into action than during action and only
15 percent experienced more fear during
action
um
it says here knowledge of the situation
lessens fear the unfamiliar is always
more fearful than the familiar you
cannot even plan how to man how to meet
a strange and ill-defined danger men in
combat should therefore be told as much
about the enemy as possible where he is
likely to be met and in what strength
what kinds of weapons he's likely use in
tactics so
people fear the unknown
habit makes fear less effective fear is
disorganizing it makes men less alert
takes their attention from important
matters causes them to act for
inadequate reasons
that is how Panic gets started but
disciplined
yes discipline discipline fortunately
controls them and gets them started on
the right actions then in action the
Mind clears up and the fear disappears
discipline is the Soldier's fear friend
in emergency it carries him through when
he might otherwise fail soldiers
sometimes report they are much more
afraid during bombardment when on
furlough in a city then when they're on
the firing line they've been trained for
battle and in battle they have their job
to do some men yield to fear more easily
than others because they have not formed
the habit of suppressing emotion and
acting on judgment there are differences
in the emotionality of people that
depend upon their habits and training
number four calm Behavior lessons fear
it lessens fear in others for both fear
and self-possession are contagious
self-possession that's a good word
having control of yourself for this
reason each man has a responsibility to
control the signs of his own fear and
the successful leader is of course a man
who can remain calm in danger if a
soldier goes to pieces and becomes
panicky then he should when possible be
removed from the sight of other men
assumed calm does moreover lessen fear
in the man who assumes it
he finds his pride working against
his Panic if you if you act calm you're
going to be calm
it's a good rule to have freaking out
doesn't help anybody
humor fights fear
and trying times intense moments a laugh
can be a lifesaver there's a story from
the first world war of American troops
facing an unexpected horror they were
being fired on by another Battalion of
their own regiment the captain was
nervous and Afraid ready to fire back on
their comrades the captain or sorry the
men were nervous and Afraid ready to
fire back on their comrades the captain
restored morale it was unintentional but
he did it Jackson he called yes Captain
where are you right here across the road
stand up so I can see you Captain
Jackson shouted in a lull between burst
of machine gun fire if you want to see
me you stand up
the chuckle that ran down the line
restored order
commands were given the men crept out of
the zone of Fire
six companionship decreases fear men
should whenever possible be within sight
or hearing of other men in the time of
battle danger although not bunched
together so they can make a common
Target the sight of another man who
seems not panicky is reassuring dude so
so good gotta watch people want to Bunch
up I wrote about that leadership
strategy and tactics don't Bunch up we
used to say that all the time in urban
combat training in land Warfare training
in on the battlefield don't Bunch up you
have to say that over and over because
people want to get close to you people
want to get close to each other there's
like a little feeling of comfort you got
to be like dude back off
knowledge of Statistics helps fear even
when casualties are heavy comparatively
few men are killed the chances that any
one man will be mortally wounded in any
one battle or small
in the entire Allied armies the first
world war the only one man in nine was
killed or died as a result of war in all
four years of fighting I'm gonna call
on that you want to know why
because most people weren't on the front
lines fighting
that's what we learned from the book I
remember the last war
that guy's like hey there's not many he
goes there's there's books about World
War One there's not about books about
From The Trenches because we didn't most
guys didn't make it
and so that's saying this is this is
saying
the chances that any one man would be
mortally wounded in one battle we're
small
in the entire Allied armies in the first
world war only one man in nine was
killed or died as a result of wounds
okay
that's all the people
that's all the people that's the people
in the rear with the gears and people in
logistics is the people that are
slogging food and ammunition up to the
front lines it's all the people that are
back in England like in their desk
writing up orders it's everyone it's
like bruh you're kind of making this a
little bit different here
uh number eight religious Faith
diminishes fear the men who believe in
God's protection and in immortality may
be greatly sustained in that period of
fear before a battle they can pray to
and for them prayer works as it has
worked for so many men throughout the
ages even the man alone in a shell hole
is not alone if he feels that God is
with him all reports from the fighting
front show that religious faith is an
efficient enemy of fear many leaders
encourage prayer before combat among
their troops few men in foxholes say
they say are atheists
there you go
loyalty works against fear
the man who lacks faith in God May
nevertheless be controlled by a deep
loyalty and responsibility to his
comrades to his unit to his leader
another important antidote for fear is
belief in the cause which he is fighting
men must have a clear idea of what's at
stake
nearly all prudent men are afraid in the
face of danger but not so many of them
are inhibited by fear are terrorized by
it
every emergency
every great danger to a group reveals
many quiet Heroes and the greater the
morale the unit the greater number of
unpretentious Heroes in it men will
crawl out of foxholes under shell fire
to gather up the remains of a shattered
comrade because
because that is the sort of men they are
affection and responsibility are not
strangers to the battlefield and they
can overcome fear number 10 good
physical condition works against fear
tired sleepy hungry men are much more
likely to be fearful than men in good
physical condition the tired man does
not think clearly he is prone to
illogical fears to belief and rumor than
the rested man the healthy man can do
something about fear the ill man lacks
the energy combat it stay in good shape
people hmm
knowing about fear reduces fears and
this is kind of what I already covered
so many inexperienced soldiers are
afraid of being afraid fear itself is
the great unknown of which they are
fearful
and this is what I was talking about if
you don't know why you feel a little bit
queasy or why you feel nervous or why
you can't stop shaking
then you're like what's wrong with me
it's okay dude
when soldiers know that fear in combat
is natural is highly contagious and
almost inevitable but that courage is
also contagious than part of the battle
against fear is one
now it goes into a section about anger
and again I just want to hit this really
quickly because
it's emotion right and we I often talk
about you have to have control over your
emotions anger is probably one of the
more damaging emotions oftentimes in the
civilian sector it stands from ego your
ego is what's driving you to become
angry
says here anger like fear is emotional
response to frustration if a man feels
that his freedom of thought or action is
threatened it makes him angry and when
his when he is angry he's likely to be
aggressive to be on the offensive people
or sorry place
any obstacle in the path of man strong
desire and he's likely to attack it
so
what's what's interesting about this is
that's all sounds good right until
you're in an administrative situation
you're getting angry and you're
attacking people that don't deserve to
be attacked and you're making the
situation worse
fear and anger often blend apparent fear
May mask anger especially when fear is
strong the child May resent the order
the bully has given him but is afraid to
say so afraid to Rebel pale and
trembling he carries out the order when
he would really like to knock the bully
down
or apparent anger May mask fear the
commanding officer worried about the
turn in battle
afraid that the enemy will overpower his
men may bark orders threaten insult and
otherwise offend the men he covers his
own fears by authoritativeness seldom
realizing that he is doing so
such a good little point
you know when that person's losing
control I've seen this in so many
examples because when I was running
trade at you know would be going
sideways and that officer would get mad
and start yelling at people the chief
would get mad and start yelling at
people like oh but here comes the
breakdown because he's not making good
decisions by the way that's crazy yep
did you see people yell in the uh in the
nightclub industry occasionally
get some you were working for some chill
people yeah not in that capacity no not
really
that's good that's a good sign
uh such blends of fear and anger
probably occur most frequently when the
situation arises anxiety arouses anxiety
anger like fear has the support of the
sympathetic nervous system is also man's
response to an emergency of any threat
to a man's vital interest or attack upon
them will arouse anger
threaten or destroy a man's cherished
property or his loved ones and his own
pride and equally beloved self-esteem
and you have almost inevitably an angry
man on your hands these are good things
to pay attention to
just think about when you hurt someone's
self-esteem
that that can bring about anger
his anger tends to warp his judgment yep
for an angry man as rarely as wise he as
he when he is calm
and his anger itself may be unreasoned
is has been said that a prize fighter
sometimes tries to get his opponent
angry so as to make him less skillful in
his
fighting so there you go
um
and it goes on to say just as all fear
is not inefficient Panic or Terror so
not all anger is blind useless Rage or
Fury anger against the enemy AIDS in
combat since it helps a man to take the
offensive yet it is surprising how
little soldier feels anger after the
intense activity of combat has begun
there is also moreover a cool sustained
anger that may motivate a man
successfully for a long period of time
he resents perhaps the crudian Injustice
and originally on
unprovoked aggression of the enemy and
he is determined upon Vengeance such
anger is good
especially when combined with the
peculiar kind of elation that comes from
Talks by able leaders before battle it
does not warp judgment unduly and is the
cause of righteous action
anger then
properly aroused directed and controlled
is useful in the services hatred on the
other hand is not useful hatred
immobilizes since hatred is repressed
anger
hatred then is to avoided except as it
is accompanied by anger
so there you go
that that is anger once aroused anger
must be properly directed
you can utilize that right you can
utilize that before your freaking
workouts you know what I'm saying
uh I used to do that with Fighters like
fighter would be mad because they're
getting frustrated make them do some
burpees like make them do something
didn't use that stuff
in any case anger ought to be controlled
by the angry man himself let him
consider whether he understands fully
the causes of his frustration so that he
can choose the right persons for the
blame let him not be Hasty but know what
he does in anger and why he does it all
right now we're going to get into this
leadership section
and it says there's no skill that the
Armed Forces need so badly as the
capacity to lead men this is true in any
industry by the way they need it because
it is vital to the working of the
military machine and they are aware of
this need because it is so inadequately
supplied
there are not enough good leaders not of
men with the capacity to establish
discipline to build morale and integrate
groups of men into efficient Fighting
Machines machines which work with little
friction and stand up without breaking
under the strain of combat now what I
love about this sentence or this whole
opening here you get the feeling that
this is going to start talking about
authoritarian leadership right hey we
need someone that's going to put
discipline establish discipline turn
people into machines that's what it's
literally saying right that's used even
as I'm reading it I'm like damn this is
going to be some big
Trope into authoritarian leadership
which I know is wrong
so I keep reading
it says
through training and discipline the Army
prepares its men to carry out its
Ultimate Missions under command and
according to plan
that is the military scheme plans can be
executed by command only because there's
discipline most persons think that
commands are enforced by Authority
but the relationship between leaders and
their men is not nearly so simple so
there we go we get safe we got saved
almost on me immediately a command to be
effective requires not only discipline
but also morale understanding and
motivation a command is not merely some
words which act like a match to a fuse
or a firing pin on a bullet command
effective command means that the men who
receive it understand it trust it and
Obey having been trained by leaders to
understand to trust and Obey leaders
have to do much more than issue orders
they must teach they must Inspire
confidence in themselves they must
motivate action which will be carried
out in spite of confusion and fear only
by long careful training can men learn
to respond immediately correctly to oral
and written orders and oral commands and
only by long careful training can men be
trained to assume responsibilities of
giving the orders and commands now we're
getting close there you know it still
talks a lot about obedience and
following commands and
again you're going to see that even
though it's saying that it starts to
shed light it starts to indicate that
that's not really what it's about
command is like a motor nervous system
for the Army and the Navy and by the way
they keep using just the Army in the
Navy that's because the Navy is of the
Marine Corps Department of the Navy and
at this time the Air Force was the Army
Air corps because that's why they just
keep start talking about the army of the
Navy
as the nervous system carries action all
the way down from the brain through the
lower nerve centers to the muscles so
command proceeds from the
commander-in-chief through the secession
of commanding officers down to the
Soldiers and Sailors who finally execute
the actions since successful command
depends on good leadership is equally
true that leadership also goes all the
way down through the line through the
CEOs and ncos every man from the
Corporal up is a leader and all the
other men are at least potential
corporals
followership is important too
and what what it leaves out in that
whole section right there is that
leadership is not just down
you leadership is up to which means I
have to take input from the people on
the front lines I have to know what's
happening I have to understand what's
working they have to be able to pass
that information back to me like the
central nervous system let's face it how
much of your nerves are outgoing from
your brain quite a lot of them are but
what about when you touch a hot stove
what about when you get cold what about
when you feel pain because you're
getting arm locked right those things
are incoming nerves
what about when it's light out those
things are incoming so this is like
talking about oh the this is only
talking about one way that the nerves go
they reality they go both directions and
the more going back to like the Free
Fall example the more sensitive you are
to how these actions that you're
commanding what reactions those things
cause is the better you're going to be
able to lead so we're in a little bit
you know where I I think they kind of
have ideas of what they're trying to say
but I don't think they're already there
I don't think they're fully developed I
think they miss some of these important
links
here and that's a actually
huge point and especially that that
comparison and analogy right in the
nervous system you know where you're
like yeah your nervous system sure
you're sending signals sure but you're
getting inputs but and when you think
about it technically you're probably
getting just as many like literally not
like one to one as many signals back as
you are sending out because like every
step you take yep you land on something
like if you land on something soft hard
slippery like that's all input coming
back yeah even when I contract my arm on
a curl when I get to the top I have to
it has to tell me that I made it to the
top and now I need to stop the whole
deal everything yeah and so leadership
is like a central nervous system but the
central nervous system goes more than
just one way yeah and that's a even like
uh and we'll bring it down kind of to
the ground level in a way where like
let's say your relationship with your
friend your wife will say you know how
they say and of course this is nothing
new where it's like communication is key
or whatever when you think about it
that's not just some Trope something
that you say to sound good or whatever
it's true like the more the more that
you what you put out you listen back
it's like you go back and forth back and
forth brother the problem solving
capability that can be developed through
that kind of like honest open
communication back forth back and forth
um and thinking about it in terms of of
that just what you said where the
nervous system is sending signals and
it's receiving signals as well equally
as important yes totally
totally and that's why
if you have let's say in this case
husband and wife
and they don't talk that something comes
up and they don't talk about it oh yeah
and now guess what
it gets worse and it festers and now
they have a real problem maybe they end
up getting divorced now you might say
well yeah but you might argue about it
hold on
not if I'm talking to my wife and I
actually listen to what she's saying
exactly that's where that's where
everything falls apart she's talking to
me but I'm not listening and I'm just
yelling back at her and now we're
yelling at each other now we have a
problem exactly we're not absorbing the
information that's coming back in our
Direction yeah and it's especially when
you think of it in terms of
the maximum amount of effective
communication that you can possibly send
and receive right where even the
smallest of problems that come up if one
guy explains where or one person
explains where they were coming from and
maybe they what expectations they had or
whatever then the other person just
explains this is before any fight
because there's no reason to fire enough
it's a teeny tiny problem and they and
then they say their part open and
honestly because they're they're not
hostile at this point they're like well
I felt this and this person's listening
to that as they're you know so now this
person understands this person
understands completely just understands
like okay I see that I understand and it
makes sense you know kind of thing but
let's say let's say one person
is quiet and just whatever doesn't say
anything whatever and that happens now
we have this little problem that's so
easily solvable all you gotta look
little things are easy to understand
typically but now you got a little thing
that turned into you think it's a bit it
feels like a big thing but this is kind
of really what it is it's a bunch of
little things that equal a big thing and
they're festering festering all in there
and it takes on this life of its own now
when this person blows up because of all
these little things which now equals one
huge huge thing they're gonna blow up
and now it's kind of inaccurate you know
it's not because it took one thing to to
cause that blow up right so now you're
like okay all those little things could
easily have been solved over time but
now you got to deal with them all at
once and not to mention the the out of
the new attitude that from the other
person standpoint because they don't
have information they didn't you know
they didn't get it seems like real
unnecessary real mean real this real
that you know so now you have that huge
problem didn't have to be like that no
no
both directions Communications gotta go
uh going on here followership is
important too all leaders as well as the
privates have to be led by leaders but
the dearth of followers is not so great
as the dearth of leaders nevertheless
follower ship is also an art and has got
to be trained
the development of morale in a unit is
largely the training of followers
when you now let's see when I first saw
that I was like oh they're gonna talk
about how a leader has to be a follower
too they didn't get they can get there
they didn't say that they talk about hey
people gotta follow you got to train
them to follow
um
don't really love that when you come
right down to the bottom of the matter
leadership and followership are
complementary now we get a little bit
more
the men with good morale accept
leadership and make it effective the
leader on the other hand has not only to
give effective direction to morale but
he is also the most potent influence in
building up morale he has to both build
it and use it what then may we ask is
leadership and what is followership
little section here leading and being
led accepting leadership is easy and
natural for most Americans
hmm okay
we're not 100 sure on that one
by the way you know I was going to say
like a little different now no this is
America and these Americans that we're
talking to like these are the same
Americans that
you know this is the Revolutionary War
Americans said we're not paying an extra
two cents for for tea screw you will
fight will will Lou give up everything
and just fight for our freedom so
accepting leadership is easy and natural
for most Americans now he says this or
the book says this that is because
they've been taught from Early Childhood
to obey commands and to accede to
requests if you should stop a stranger
on the street point to the top of
building and say to him look the chances
are that he will stop and look that's
pretty accurate this is especially true
if you say it in a voice of command with
a matter of authority in a manner of
authority such immediate unquestioned
acceptance of command is called
suggestion a great deal of leadership
depends on suggestion
and then it goes into this thing which
I'm not going to go through because it
starts talking about the extreme form of
suggestion is hypnosis and I think we'd
have to do like a whole uh thing because
I need to get some kind of a
professional hypnotist or something
because I don't understand it very well
it seems weird to me like you can tell
me I'm gonna act like a chicken or
whatever and then I actually act like it
have you ever been hypnotized no you've
been to a hypnotism show I've been a
show I've been the subject actually
sorry I wasn't subject I was assisting
with the subject it's like real right
okay so okay there's varying levels of
like the whole gig the whole deal where
on a this is from what I understand for
on a scientific level like the real deal
that certain people it's a spectrum of
people that are what's called
susceptible suggestible okay yeah so you
get highly suggestible people you can
hypnotize them where they can act like a
chicken or they'll feel actual feelings
pain whatever itchiness or whatever and
then there's people who like it just
doesn't affect them
so that's what it kind of says too
um and then again then it gets into this
here it says the problem of leadership
is the problem of Social ascendance and
submission
if we use these words in their technical
senses in every social relation between
two people there has to be a certain
amount of adjustment the most natural
adjustment is for one person to assume
leadership and the other followership
there are many different degrees of
ascendance and submission in different
people and even in the same person in
different situations
take people as you find them this is a
very interesting uh idea
basically you know what I say a lot is
subordinate your ego
that's what he's talking about here like
well that's what they're talking about
here submission is like I'm gonna
subordinate my ego and listen Echo but
they also have a different thing which
is ascendance which is I'm gonna rise up
and you will subordinate your ego to me
that sounds real harsh when I say it but
as we get in it's it's a it's a
important thing that we should be able
to do
I think
this is going to be accurate you'll see
as we read through it um
uh take people as you find them and some
are much more ready to lead than others
more ready to assert themselves to
suggest to others what they should do it
is an interesting fact however that it
and a good omen for the need of the
armed forces that submissive persons can
more readily learn to be ascendant than
ascendant persons can learn to be
submissive at least that's true in
America both of these traits of course
have great military what's it's so if
I'm an ascendant type personality it's
harder for me to be submissive
if I'm if you're a submissive type
personality it's easier to teach you hey
you can be assigned it too an ascendant
means essentially like being able to
step up step up yeah yeah okay a
sentence means I'm gonna step up but as
we talk about all the time if I lack
humility then I'm like I'm not gonna
listen that's exactly what they're look
I'll lead Echo you want to put me in
charge I got this but wait you want me
to work for Echo not doing that yeah so
it's it's exactly but if you if you're
an A submissive type personality and
they're like hey Echo you know we got to
put you we want you running this program
which Aqua you're like oh okay
whereas if you had an ascendant type
person hey we want you to be under
jockey yeah
so that's a pretty good point that's
interesting I never
I don't know I never thought of that I
never like that I wouldn't have known
the answer like if that was a multiple
choice question like oh what do you
think is harder statistically or
whatever you know whatever this based on
what's harder the guy to step up and
leave it if he's a quiet uh submissive
or send it I I would not have no answer
yeah it doesn't even from all the things
that we've talked about on this podcast
for the past seven years
you wouldn't have said hey as you oh you
got arrogant Fred over here yeah and you
say hey arrogant Fred I want you to you
know work for Jessica yeah he's like no
way I'm doing that yeah whereas if you
take humble Fred and you're like hey
Fred we want you to lead this we think
you have the potential he goes well okay
I can do that yeah I would say this
that's a good question and I thought
about that but I I just
I thought I'm kind of around people who
know the game a lot right now so they
know to you know subordinate their ego
with I don't know what the real world
out there kind of looks like it feels
like
each of them like if one was harder than
the other no matter what the answer was
I would be like okay that makes sense
that makes sense but
for to find out that answer it's like
huh that's that's interesting that that
is distinctly the case makes total sense
to me
um
accepting the role of being led is
discipline interesting use while
ascendant men do not accept discipline
easily they can nevertheless learn to
accept it and fortunately it is not so
difficult for men to be submissive in
new situations where they lack a feeling
of confidence that makes total sense so
it's easier if I show up and I'm gonna
be
on the computer programming team I'm not
rolling in there like all right guys
listen up nope I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
this submissive I'm not gonna be
ascendant in that situation I don't have
any confidence there then if ever they
accept without difficulty control by
others who are competent by men whose
right to leadership is clear to them so
when I see someone that knows what
they're doing that's why competence is
very important that's why you know I I
went like one of the first times I
talked to the Troops at trade at to the
to the guys
and I rolled in there I had said like a
little notebook and I had six bullet
points I was going to talk about and
like we walked out and one of my buddies
is like dude you freaking squared away I
was like what do you mean he goes dude
you just rolled in there and just put
out word and I was like
I was like well thanks man he goes yeah
like I see you you just have your
notebook you're ready yeah and it's like
that little thing that little thing is
like oh he's confident you know like
just a little thing like oh yeah I got
some stuff to say here's what I'm not
saying I know everything but hey here's
some points here's what I'm looking at
but whatever he's like you're so
freaking squared away you know and it's
always nice right he was excited about
it yeah
so confidence goes a long way yeah I
like the expression put out word by the
way yeah you put out word that's a good
big expression in the military now here
we get to some good stuff
in America the best leadership assumes
the Democratic character rather than the
character of unilateral suggestion the
leader does not demand obedience without
an explanation if he's in a position to
let his followers see the reason for his
decision so now we're getting into
whether you you know that somebody was
like hey hold on a second dude that
don't make sense they're starting to put
out some good word here
nor does he arbitrarily make demands
upon the followers as to the details of
the action rather he invites initiative
encourages cooperation instead of
sub-operation sets a problem exhibits
means for its solution in as far as they
are known to him and asks his
subordinates to Carry On from there so
it's like hey here's the mission how do
you guys want to get it done
quite properly he accepts advice from
his subordinates although he never
transfers to them responsibility for his
decisions perfect this is perfect we're
nailing this that means if I'm in charge
and I'm like Echo how do you want to get
this done and you say I want to attack
from the west and then the attack fails
like oh who's uncle's idea no hey it was
my decision
that's what we did it was a failure it's
on me
that principle Works excellent in
Industry Works excellently in Industry
as well as with the direction of
children and there is increasing
evidence that it works in the Army and
Navy too well thank you
opposed to such Democratic Leadership is
authoritarian leadership where the
leader commands arbitrarily and the far
and the follower under threat of
punishment if he fails executes the
command without participation in the
decisions or the exercise of initiative
and carrying them out
boom authoritarian leadership sucks
there is no doubt that discipline can be
enforced this way as indeed it has been
most cruelly enforced by the Gestapo in
German concentration camps their men
their men came ultimately to accept the
gestapo's point of view about the
propriety of their own submissiveness
this kind of discipline however secures
obedience but not achievement for it is
based on fear not loyalty the Germans do
not use it in their Armed Forces
and we've talked we've gone through
German
Armed Forces manuals that clearly point
this out in the army they expect leaders
to encourage the soldiers to participate
in solving problems to use initiative in
their accomplishment of their missions
to a certain degree the German officer
is asked to fraternize with his men in
order to maintain morale and initiative
in them even though he must at no time
break down their sense of his
superiority and responsibility nor their
Reliance on him for the ultimate
decisions
so
they they definitely recognized in
writing this that this authoritarian
thing that this imposed discipline was
not the deal it's not good did he say
they encouraged yeah
like hey you gotta get to know your
people yeah you gotta let them come up
with an initiative you got to let them
come up with problem solving
he says to a certain degree the German
officers asked to fraternize with his
men in order to maintain morale an
initiative in them
that's what we're doing
so the good soldier or sailor accepts
leadership in part by discipline
this means that the relation of the
ascendance of the leader and the
submission of the followers established
that instantaneous obedience is thus
always obtained even when the reasons
for such obedience cannot be disclosed
immediately
so look you and I have a relationship
and we're working together and most of
the time I'm telling you what's going on
but then all of a sudden I'm like Echo
you need to get to my house now you're
like cool I'll be there that's not the
norm it's a lot of leadership Capital
I'm spending like if I just text you hey
come to my house now hey meet me at the
studio in 15 minutes like maybe I didn't
have time to explain that we got a you
know a news crew coming in and they
wanted well they want to meet with you
or whatever I don't have time to tell
you all that it's gonna cost me some
leadership Capital that's not the
optimal way to do it
the follower must have habits of
attention and obedience these habits
must moreover be firmly rooted in his
nervous system they must have they must
become second nature to him how are such
habits formed by motivation and practice
by practice it goes this is a rough way
to do this by practice you teach a dog
to salivate when a dinner bell is rung
for him provided he really wants food
you simply always ring the bell before
you give him food at first the Bell
means nothing to him and his saliva does
not begin to flow until he sees food but
after many repetitions this is the
Pavlov's dog thing
that new relationship will not keep her
life but it will continue as long as the
bell actually leads to what he expects
as long as you continue giving food
after ring the bell so it's basically
saying like a little bit of pavlovian
training for your dogs classical
conditioning e-dogs classical
conditioning discipline that arises
through drill and practice comes about
in the same manner through the building
of habits and it goes into this pretty
interesting thing
you know you you know you see in the
movies a lot when when the military
command is giving a tan John right you
heard that right yeah no doubt about it
um it just talks about how that is this
fundamental thing that you learn and
it's basic to discipline because when
that happens like the leader's gonna say
something like it's a it's a basic form
of attention and what happens is
eventually you get to a point where
that's not even being said anymore but
when the leader walks in people are
quiet they're like waiting for the word
yeah
so uh I've heard the expression 10 hot I
think they say just a modified version
it's the same thing yeah okay got it but
I gotta say that when I got to Shield T1
instead I don't know where this came
from
but it's awesome in the SEAL Teams you
don't say attention on deck which is
what you say when the commanding officer
comes on a ship okay they just they'd
say on your feet and then eventually it
just became feet so like the command
option would be a fruit and it would
stand up pretty cool that is cool pretty
cool with your feet yep
um so discipline is calculated to ensure
this preliminary attention by placing
certain restrictions on Behavior
whenever an officer is present and
appears to be on the scene
when the Habit has become second nature
then it is part of the soldiers or
Sailors standard equipment it can be
taken for granted and be presumed when
active thought needs to be given to
something less routine so this is just
like something you learn
the Boss shows up you're going to be
quiet
and then it goes through this again and
again military success turns out to
depend on good leadership
no kidding no wonder leadership is
considered important when good leaders
are so hard to find and takes a longer
train another thing which the follower
contributes to the success of the
leadership is his pride a man who is
praised can be me more easily LED than
one who's blamed
when the leader criticizes he will
usually speak impersonally condemning
poor work not the man leaving the man's
Pride untouched letting Pride work to
make him do better job next time the
leader therefore tries to develop each
man's belief in his own indispensiality
in the unit as he can do in the course
of training by making special
assignments to particular men this is
that whole thing I wrote about
leadership strategy and tactics where I
told all my guys they were the most
important person to platoon and they
were it's not a lie well there's a
freaking wounded guy that corman's most
important when we need fire support and
rate him it's most important when we're
on patrol the point man's most important
we get a gunfight machine Gunners most
born I'm telling them all that they're
most important guy in the platoon
we get into the attributes of leadership
and this is where they start to recover
a little bit
um or at least go further and and more
positively there have been studies in of
leadership and civilian life among
Children's Group and in industry in
these studies the authoritarian attitude
of the leader has been contrasted with
the Democratic attitude authoritarian
leaders have been retrained as
Democratic Leaders with great success
and greatly improved results in the
effect of their leadership boom I should
just end the podcast right there
authoritarian leadership doesn't work
and it gives some really good examples
it gives one of about a a foreman
dealing with some Union folks here it
says this in this in a study of garment
workers in a Southern Factory
the foreman had the job of training
beginners these Foreman received eight
hours of training from a psychologist in
methods of increasing personal contact
with the workers and of changing their
attitude toward their men from an
aggressive high pressure
authoritarianism to a friendly and
encouraging leadership
in this relation the worker came to feel
that the foreman was his friend and was
working for him as well as for the
management the result of this Democratic
relationship was a definite increase in
morale as well as an increase in
productivity presently beginners were
able to learn in one week which had
previously taken five
this experiment shows that important
changes in the ability to exercise
leadership can be procured by even a
little training of leaders this teaching
people to be cool
good leadership never creates slaves
it establishes the feeling of
responsibility and initiative in those
who are LED see this is nailing it now
so you probably had a couple different
people in the room there was that one
freaking jackass that was like you
people need to just listen to me if I'm
outranking them they should just lock it
up and do what I say there was an
like that in the room when they
were writing the stuff but luckily the
good leaders were able to put these
sentences into these paragraphs in here
out of such attitudes come the best
morale the quickest learning the most
effective action
a subordinate does not need to feel
inferior when a superior makes him feel
that he's contributing voluntarily to
the success of a common Enterprise in
fact the leader himself succeeds only
when he re assumes the role of
commanding servant to his men and to the
whole military Enterprise so that idea
of servant leadership I forget who wrote
a book about it
but there's a big popular book servant
leadership here we are 1945.
the commanding servant and we covered a
podcast on
serve to lead about the British
leadership
methodologies same thing this is not a
new idea
when you're in charge you're not in
charge you're a servant to your men
what makes a good leader then
this is I was a little nervous says
number one Authority
the leader starts out with authority the
military and Naval systems give it to
him his uniform gives it to him
Authority is essential to discipline it
forms the background of all leadership
you're like oh damn this is not what
Jocko talks about it's definitely not
what I believe in and then it says yet
most of the power that the leader needs
in order to lead well is not given to
him he wins it for himself he must win
the respect and loyalty of his men so
that they trust his judgment he must
lead not drive them he must build up
their morale such Powers depend on his
own attributes not on anything that goes
ready made with his rank so they took
back everything they said hmm
personal characteristics and attitudes
good leader must be competent which I
pointed out a little earlier
he must know his stuff
industry must work hard
right the men must feel that the leader
shares the hardships with them
the leader must be decisive conf it must
have a decisive confident manner
the leader must always be ready to
accept responsibility
yeah we're talking about extreme
ownership
Soldiers and Sailors are ready to be
commanded but they have to know what it
is they have to do the leader has to
decide this not all these decisions have
been made quickly have to be made
quickly often he can ponder the best
course of action he can take advice even
from subordinates but he must keep for
himself all responsibility for his
judgment he cannot shift that to others
often he has to make a decision either
after consideration and advice or
immediately an emergency on insufficient
evidence he must learn therefore that
good judgment is not tested by its
success
often the best judgment on evidence at
hand leads to action that fails when a
different judgment might have succeeded
the leader must keep reminding himself
of this truth nor must he blame himself
when the best possible judgment under
the circumstances proves to have been
the wrong one this is why I wrote a book
called leadership strategy and tactics
and talked about the iterative
decision-making process because if you
don't have all the information make a
small decision and be ready to make
adjustments
that's the that's the move
very seldom do you have to figure
everything out in one shot and just make
the call
you don't normally need to do that you
make a little call and you can make
adjustments
closely related to acceptance of spot
responsibility is self-possession the
leader must be a man who can keep his
head in emergencies he must be able to
control fear in his men the gnawing fear
that grows out of inaction in the
presence of danger
can he joke
when he himself is frightened
he must be able to control frenzy the
wild pointless inefficient and often
foolhardy action that may take hold of
panicky men he must be able to keep his
head to let his sense of responsibility
put him above fear and panic or at least
must not show fear that fear grips him
some men find they have this
self-possession when they meet an
emergency some acquire it through
training and handling emergencies and
repeated experience with confusion and
danger
there are doubtless many who cannot
learn it
and they should be chosen not be chosen
to lead so there you go you have a
little limiting capacity if you freak
out all the time bro you shouldn't freak
out you should train to Not freak out
you train to Not freak out with
everything that you do when you're
driving when your printer breaks when
your kids do something stupid when you
do something stupid like
you should train and not freak out you
shouldn't use freak out words
you shouldn't use words that are freaked
out what's a freak out word uh
catastrophic
that's a freak out one that is a
freakout word isn't it like failure yeah
like those kind of words yeah I don't
say those kind of words you know what
you know what would have to be happening
for me to say something is catastrophic
what uh
burning fire in the skies with metal
aliens attacking us yeah and even then
I'd be kind of fired up there's no
reason to say it it seems like I don't
know
look my my catastrophic scenario
experience is very limited
very little
pretty much zero
but he I even with my imagination I'm
thinking hey
in a catastrophic situation aliens what
have you
can I imagine Jocko saying this is
catastrophic no not really yeah
some catastrophic language I mean Jamie
has told me some things where it's like
gonna be a bad day for like a bad
situation like maybe there's money and
you know I've always been okay Roger
that you know that Roger that's the best
um the best term to use oh yeah yeah in
those in catastrophic situations but
there's you're just not gonna be
remember we had a a question on the
Underground the guy said he had a
catastrophic injury oh yeah and my
immediate thought was like oh this guy's
paralyzed from the neck down this guy's
lost a couple limbs it turned out what
do you have like a broken finger or
something
yours was yours is a peck it was a peck
I think if I'm not maybe it was a peck
maybe it was a torn pack benching but
you know for him it was catastrophic and
I as soon as I was like oh you got a
torn Peck like you can get surgery and
get that fixed and carry on with the
rest of your life yeah like hey bro
that's not catastrophic it seems
catastrophic in your head go tell that
to freaking Rob Jones and he's like what
are you talking about catastrophic right
with no legs and I'm over here running
30 on marathons what
like what's your problem yeah so they
deal it I mean okay so what what how did
you say it you said don't use what kind
of language don't use Music
Panic language yeah it just sounds bad
yeah so catastrophic actually
technically doesn't necessarily have to
be a panic language but it that's an
example of something you would use in in
panic language no
I'm saying don't use that language
unless you can verifiably say that
something is catastrophic yeah
like if you were in charge of Silicon
Valley bank right now yeah you could be
like we've had a catastrophic situation
yeah right like but even that people I
mean I'm assuming if you said it the way
you just said it that's technically not
panic language you're just stating kind
of effect okay but on whatever day it
was and you're talking to your you know
the rest of your executive team and
you're like hey this is a catastrophic
situation we've got to run people are
there's a run on our bank right now and
we are not gonna we need to salvage what
we can because we're going down yeah
that that would be a situation where
you'd say Yep this is a catastrophic
situation
you know uh FTX the the crypto guy right
that guy I don't know what he was
thinking because he just seems like he's
out of touch with reality yeah
Sam bankman freed right
so he didn't he he I doubt I don't think
he actually recognized I don't know I'd
I'd have to dig more into the case right
but he just seemed like he just was lost
yeah and and just super aloof and
arrogant and thinking you know when
people think they're super smart yes and
they think they can outsmart people I
think he's been like that for his whole
life oh yeah and he's been building upon
that and he's been getting away with it
for a long time so I think this was just
another little thing that he was going
to scam his way out of in his mind so he
might not have even recognized it as
catastrophic oh yeah yeah
yeah it seems like that could be the
case yeah I mean he didn't really
recognize that he was a dork
but yeah it makes sense though I made
back to the original point where it's
like hey don't use um was it Panic
language do that yeah so it's less about
necessarily the actual words but like
under panicky situations there's a bunch
of words that hey man this is about the
actual words though like it is about
it's about the words it's about the
behavior that behavior those words are
are panicked Behavior right yeah if you
start using words like that
then it's a problem and P and by the way
now people are it's now it turns into
the boy that cried wolf right yeah where
when something really bad does happen
yeah like it's no one really is paying
attention to you because you've been
saying that the sky is falling you're
saying that the wolf is attacking for
the past for previous parts of your life
yeah and now you say something's a real
problem and it's like oh yeah
I mean catastrophic is catastrophic is a
isn't to me is like first of all
imminent yeah right imminent situation
because I can get out all kinds of stuff
right yeah well you know I'm gonna get
out I'm gonna figure something out we're
gonna make Maneuvers that's what we do
we're gonna go figure things out what
about the word critical
that's that's that's a stepstone right
that's a stepstone towards catastrophic
sure most most cases not necessary right
yeah that's why I kind of thought of it
because you're like when you made the
boy who cried cries wolf analogy
that's true that's and actually that's
probably in in my experience which is
almost none the
most common scenario of why this panicky
or catastrophic type language can be so
um like detrimental because you know how
I think you just said it today where if
everything is a an Emergency then
nothing's an emergency or something like
that yeah I'm I'm sure I have said that
I'm certainly that's a very common
phrase right yeah if if everything's an
emergency nothing's an emergency if
everything's in a priority nothing's a
priority yeah so it's like stop if
everything's special if everything's
special nothing special if everything's
catastrophic nothing's catastrophic yeah
the only thing that's catastrophic is
your leadership ability which is going
downhill so you got to be careful about
this
right you've got to be careful about
this because then you end up people just
kind of shrug their shoulders and like
oh Jocko's running around like a chicken
with his head cut off man we used to
have some leaders like in the SEAL Teams
where you they would Panic about stuff
you know dumb stuff and they're freaking
out and you're like dude like no one is
listening to you right now stop stop
just try and be relaxed try and
self-possess
the leader is a man who can keep his
head on in emergencies if you can't keep
your head on when there's like a a DV
distinguished visitor showing up like in
the in the SEAL Teams like a DV might be
showing up that's the the expression yep
a DV like a distinguished visitor so it
might be a four-star general might be a
three-star Admiral might be a a member
of Congress might be the vice president
or president United States DVD showing
up and what do you do freak out lose
your mind
it's like dude what is wrong with you I
don't know and and by the way there's
people that DV is like in Captain insano
comes out right yeah whereas you know
just like oh we got a message from the
CEO he wants this
like dude hey man training officer wants
something let's just get it for him we
didn't know you freak out what are we
doing
so let's maintain self-possession I
don't you I've never used this
expression before self-possession but I
like it yeah
uh leader must have integrity and let
his men see that he has it sincerity
builds morale hypocrisy gets found out
and destroys morale
the leader must play no favorites and
let his men see that he plays none
men of the Armed Forces want leaders who
do not save the dirty work for the
fellows they don't like
um leader must work as hard as the men
again that's the leadership strategy
tactics finally the leader must have
teaching ability this is a very
interesting one so when I don't I don't
say maybe I need to add it to the list
the leader must have teaching abilities
Soldiers and Sailors have to learn in
order to succeed they know this and want
a man who can teach them what to do and
teach them to do it well it's a very
good point
that I like the leader's relations to
his men of course
and this is again where we get back into
like I'm like thank you you know you can
see that there are some different people
in the rooms you know
Colonel Pogue is in there with colonel
hackworth
and Colonel Pogues putting out some bad
word
but then Colonel hackworth comes in and
says of course
all of the leaders personal qualities
have to do with his relations to his men
for leadership is that relationship
the leader must know his men understand
them be loyal to them and proud of them
must work with them and for them there
are however many other special rules
which help in the relationship and then
it goes into using personal recognition
using praise doing good critical you
know how to give criticism properly they
talk a lot about giving criticism to
the job not the man so if echo's video
is substandard I don't say Echo you
messed up this video I say hey Echo I
think this video could be better I'm not
attacking you I'm attacking the video
it's a good good little point to
remember
uh the met and this is another where we
you know Colonel kernel hack or kernel
combat we'll say because hackworth
wasn't
in the Army yet in 1945.
who's just getting in the Army in 1945 I
believe maybe 1946. so Colonel Combat
versus Colonel Pogue Colonel combat says
the men need to know the reasons for
what they do what at whenever the leader
knows the reasons himself and such
knowledge is consistent with military
requirements
the need in Maneuvers to know what it's
all about sorry they need in Maneuvers
to know what it's all about so people
are supposed to know what's going on
they are not machines even though this
whole book started off saying man or
machines they are not machines they can
think too and like to know that their
leader believes they can think Soldiers
and Sailors are interested in a long
time strategy as well as immediate
objectives
many are concerned with the remote
ideology of the war
all are vitally concerned with today's
problems these principles hold both in
training and in combat so yes freaking
men are supposed to know what's going on
military leaders should train his men to
expect surprises and reverses good good
call the leader should have in mind the
effects of mental strain upon his men
he should encourage his men in all
devices that will help them to stand up
mentally in combat he should encourage
religious faith and those who already
use it he may even good naturally
encourage superstition
by not poking fun at it and those men
who find security from danger in that
fashion you got that lucky uh rabbit's
foot
cool
it is especially important that the
leader should teach his men the right
attitude toward death he must speak to
them as if the important thing were to
live for the day he must keep telling
them that death itself matters
much less than how you die
you die let your death count for
something he must teach respect for the
dead when affection for a comrade
continues after death a soldier fears
his own death less
I was trying to think how does this
relate to like uh business
failure what's your attitude towards
failure like if you're a sales guy and
I'm like hey dude you go out there go
hard you get some door slammed in your
face right on you know what I mean like
that kind of attitude towards failure
in times of danger or fear the leader
must plan activity we know that already
from that other chapter offense is the
best defense in the realm of the Mind
as well as in Grand strategy the leader
should try and give his men the attitude
of Perpetual offense
a good leader adapts his commands to his
subordinates he needs to have constantly
in mind that particular men whose action
he requires the principle holds for it
for the Corporal and his squad for the
colonel and his staff a few succinct
words of command will do for one man
more elaborate explanation is needed for
another so you have to talk to people
differently
and I might have to address echo in a
different way than I talk to Leif
because Echo might not care what the
details are and life needs to know some
details of what's going on
and a good leader keeps his immediate
subordinates from feeling isolated from
him he keeps contact be Corporal or
Colonel his men depend on him and must
know that he has not forgotten them and
their mission He makes himself available
to listen to their personal problems and
advises them to the best of his ability
so know your men
and then it goes into the leader as a
symbol although the leader takes account
of all these personal relationships
between him and his men and uses them as
motives in building morale and
accomplishing missions he is to men he
is to his men in the last analysis a
symbol rather than another man he
represents to them the authority to
which they are willing if they have good
morale to admit to submit
any final
admonition to a leader should be do not
let your men down
if a man complains do not tell him you
don't like the service any more than he
does such remarks destroy the man's
confidence and his leader and discourage
him from striving for advancement
the leader's rights to personal
satisfaction are less than his men's
so your right to personal satisfaction
as a leader is less than your men's for
the men depend on him to be what they
think their leader should be they want
they want to be proud of him and they
may have to accept and he may have to
accept loneliness and many other
discomforts in order to give them what
they have a right to demand of him he
must find his satisfaction in his own
Pride as a successful leader
so there's the qualities of a leader
this section is called selection of
leaders
it has been said that there can be no
rigid system of selection of leaders
because good leaders differ so much from
each other in personality that there
would be that there would seem to be
many different patterns of Personality
Each of which would succeed as a leader
such a statement means however little
more than that a few qualities are
essential and the best leaders are still
not perfect so cool very hard to judge
who's going to be a good leader
must also be remembered that qualities
of good leaders will vary to some extent
with the character of the men to be led
and the nature of the job a good leader
of college students or a good labor
leader might not fit the military
requirements a good leader of a unit of
one armies in one of the Army's service
Corps would not necessarily be a good
leader of combat troops
honestly I kind of disagree with that
I kind of I think that if someone truly
is a good very good leader
then
they will be adaptable
the problem is there's very few very
good leaders so for instance and so I
guess I do agree with it I said I didn't
agree with it but I do you know some
some
companies while they're in the startup
phase they need that cowboy guy that's
making things happen making deals but
then by the time it's time to go public
they need to get rid of that guy he's a
freaking
he's a liability right this happens Uber
that's what happened with Uber you had
the leader of uber and he was kind of
like a cowboy making things happen
making deals like doing things that were
out you know illegal outside but he was
making it happen but by the time they
were going public they're like hey dude
you got to go
right but the problem is that he didn't
adapt properly um
he didn't say okay I see I gotta play a
different game now yeah why is that
because like the this the state the
current state whatever that state may be
or whatever that current might mean
like the the company or the group or the
organization is gonna behave in
different ways throughout different
phases kind of a thing I mean especially
the leader has to lead in a different
way like
when you when you got a startup when you
start Uber or whatever you got like 17
people that work for you you know them
all you can like give them direct
guidance every single day yeah when you
have a thousand people all of a sudden
it's like hey you need to be a much more
much more uh versed well-versed in
decentralized command you need to give
you need to give more simple clear
concise Direction like all those things
come into play you need to utilize the
laws of combat more efficiently
when you're in charge of seven people
the laws of combat you can kind of get
away with stuff you don't really need
decentralized command you can give
complex words because you can straighten
people out you can handle a bunch of
priorities because you're not that big
yet yeah the the more people you lead
and the bigger your operation the better
you better get it the four laws of
combat leadership yeah
and there's certain levels of for
instance with the Uber thing like
professionalism yeah like you can't you
can't be the same guy and if and if
you're a really good leader that's why I
say I disagree with it because if you're
a really good leader you go okay time
for me to be more professional time for
me to wear a suit when I go to Wall
Street meet with Bankers or whatever
instead of being like Oh I wear a hoodie
you know what I mean like that kind of
thing yeah that makes sense you have to
grow up even in a seal platoon like
as I went up the ranks I had to adjust
myself and be like I can't be doing that
anymore yeah you know and sometimes I'd
be like ooh I shouldn't have said that
you know because when you're in E5 and
the E5 Mafia and somebody screws up
you're like hey you freaking jackass
right but when you're the platoon
commander and someone messes up and you
say Hey you freaking jackass or carries
a lot more weight you made him look bad
in front of everybody like it's about
it's a problem you gotta you gotta
become more mature yeah you know not
even necessarily more mature but you got
to mature as leader and in the seal
platoon yes that means you got to become
more mature yeah yeah that makes sense
actually even even like on a social
level you can kind of almost feel that
play itself out where you can be with
you and your two best friends hanging
out you can be swearing you can say
offensive stuff or whatever but then
what if you got you your two best
friends maybe their neighbors maybe you
know and the group starts to get bigger
oh you're like your best friend's wives
are over now yeah and then you're over
there dropping f-bombs like yeah it's a
problem exactly right so yeah you kind
of gotta narrow it down
and that's a perfect way to put it you
got to be more sure where everyone will
accept your
your the word you put out it'll land on
people the more people better so
ultimately you can have the correct
influence on the correct amount of
people which is now bigger yep that's
the way it works you gotta grow so a
good leader and and just like in a seal
platoon like in certain combat
situations you kind of want a guy that's
a little bit more
raw but if that guy can then walk in to
brief the general and be squared away
that's what we're looking for if he
walks in there's like Hey general I'll
tell you what's up like you oh go record
go record me talking to my platoon and
then record me talking to the general
I'm the same person but the language
that I'm using is different the even the
physical sort of gesturing I'm going to
use is different like you you're gonna
have to be able to play both those roles
and I'm not saying like oh you walk in
front of the general and you turn into a
totally different person and you're
kissing ass or you are not you know if
I'm saying to the boys hey we're to go
freaking kill everybody and I walk in
the general and say hey we really want
to are looking forward to winning the
hearts and Minds like that's a different
message but if I say hey boys we're
gonna go out and kill people and I tell
the general Hey listen sir we're gonna
go out there we're gonna eliminate the
enemy wherever we find them we're gonna
be on on you know doing as much as we
possibly can to interdict them I'm
saying the same exact thing yeah yeah
but I'm being professional yeah
so now moving on in combat the best you
can hope for is a versatile leader who
can adjust himself somewhat to different
kinds of men this is what I just said no
leader can be for Perfection for all
educated and uneducated men will need
different qualities for the leaders
strong athletic outspoken men and weak
sensitive quiet men ideally should have
different sorts of leaders to whom now
see this is where I disagree like if
you're a good leader you can talk to the
what do they call them
strong athletic outspoken men and you
can also talk to the weak sensitive
quiet men and by the way you're gonna
end up with a super tune with both those
kinds maybe not weak but sensitive quiet
guys for sure
the Germans have tried to test for
initiative and responsibility by giving
men actual military problems to solve in
spite of inadequate resources they want
to see whether the men will give up come
back for help or solve the problem in
some special way if you are given the
materials to build a bridge across the
stream and there is not enough materials
if the Timbers are the wrong size or do
not fit together what will you do
you can cut down some trees to
supplement the insufficient Timbers or
tie Parts together when there are not
enough spikes there are possibilities in
such procedure but leadership is
something greater than Ingenuity in
meeting emergency so that even that
doesn't answer the question
and then it says this the consequence of
all this that leadership can best be
judged by actual performance under the
conditions and with the kind of group in
question this is why I had the best job
when I was running tradex because I got
to put guys in the actual situation they
were going to be in
and then you put them through judgment
it talks about how you judge people how
you would how you would select leaders
you'd have to use judges put them in the
actual scenario the type that they were
going to be in that the judges had to be
competent that's better to have multiple
judges instead of just one so it goes
through that whole thing and then we get
into
after the selection of leader gets to
training of leaders are leaders born or
made obviously both a man who combines
the intelligence and ambition necessary
for him to be a competent and
resourceful leader with great interest
in the welfare of his immediate
Associates has the first requisites of
being a good leader our intelligence
ambition and human interest inborn or
learned it depends on how you define
these terms
and it goes to talk about some of the
stuff we were talking about earlier the
brightest of men are not able to
exercise their intelligence when they
are over fatigued undernourished in want
of oxygen fevered or drunk
and they cannot make wise decisions if
they are without experience in any given
situation
and it says most psychologists use the
word intelligence to refer to the native
or inborn capacity for Learning and for
adapting to the environment intelligence
in this sense cannot be learned it is
inherited but what a man does with his
inherited intelligence the extent to
which a man is ambitious or the extent
to which he is interested in his fellows
depends on how he was brought up in even
upon his environment at the present time
so you've got a certain level this is
this is exactly what I talk about
leadership strategy and tactics you get
a certain level of blessing got that you
got that certain certain level of
natural gifts natural talents in every
category of being a leader
and then you got to try and improve them
certainly there are great differences in
aptitude for leadership among men as
they enter the army or navy the question
of whether these differences are the
result of heredity or are the effects of
early training and environment has no
practical importance in the selection of
men for training as officers they don't
even care
leadership improves The Experience
that's factual
in most cases
because you can get Negative experience
and you can become a worse leader right
leadership can be learned
given some aptitude and enough
motivation that's totally true
confidence can be acquired with
intelligence motivation and practice
that's true
interest in other men can be increased
by motivation and that means that the
man who wants to become a good leader
can make his men a special object of
study
teaching ability and Clarity and
confidence of command follow along as
soon as the would-be leader has his
attention fixed on what his men are
getting from him instead of what he
thinks he is giving to them
civilian studies on training leaders in
industry and in dealing with children
all show that it is possible to learn by
voluntary effort to take the followers
point of view and see from their angle
and so to become more effective leaders
boom oh yeah
totally awesome statement
you can learn
how to take other people's perspective
and you understand the perspective of
the people that you're leading you will
do a better job
decisiveness can be learned if the
would-be leader cannot make up his mind
quickly let him make it up slowly taking
advice then when he has made his
decision let him announce it decisively
and let him stick to it I have a big
question mark next to that because if
the leader makes a bad call he shouldn't
stick to it
but you can get better at making
decisions I mean when you when we put
guys through uh trade at put them
through land Warfare you'd see him be a
disaster in the beginning could make
decisions and then they start to learn
how to make decisions and then they'd be
good at it it's freaking awesome that's
how I know this stuff can be taught
because I taught it
the would-be leader has best patterned
himself on some skill leader whom he
knows well and admires yes absolutely
he'll be surprised to find how many of
the accomplished leaders attributes he
can copy when he cannot copy the habits
of thought he may at least be able to
imitate the manner and behavior of his
model an inappropriate appropriate
habits though of thought may follow
later
so you like basically act like that guy
and then eventually hopefully you can
become that guy
our leaders border made all leaders are
made
um
makes you think wait a second and then
it says whether the aptitude upon which
they build is inborn or learned cannot
be said not all grown men have it
okay
true
but those that have what leadership
takes even though they have never LED
can learn to lead yes I agree 100 here
as everywhere else among military skills
the two keys to the creation of
successful ability must be employed
selection and training select potential
trainers and lead them there you go and
we're going to close this one out right
now the the kind of closing chapter the
use of psychology and War but it's kind
of just a good way to sum up what we've
talked about today psychology is the
study of acting man of human thinking
and behaving and of the underlying
causes and conditions of man's thought
and conduct thus it is concerned with
perceiving feeling learning remembering
thinking and acting and all and also
with all of those social relations
between men how they feel about one
another and act towards you towards one
another
the armed forces are organized bodies of
men
to make military organizations efficient
you have therefore to know about the
capacities and limitations of men about
differences among men and how one man
can be best at one job while another is
best at a different job and about the
ability of men to have their abilities
Changed by training you have also to
know about men's motives and their
personalities about their adjustment in
novel situations about
how they learn to like to do what they
have to do about how they about how and
why they break down when adjustment is
impossible
and you need to know about their social
relations in leadership and followership
in panic and accepting and spreading
rumor
all that
is psychology which the military man
needs
and there you have it
thinking about thinking
about what we're thinking about what our
boss is thinking about what our team is
thinking that is psychology which yes
the military man needs but I'll tell you
what all human beings
interacting with other human beings
we all need
more understanding
so there you go
Echo Charles yes sir speaking of need
yeah
we need to fuel ourselves we do we need
to get fuel in ourselves and that's why
we have
Jocko fuel what do you got I'm fueled up
right now yeah as a matter of fact I'm
with you so yes Jocko fuel okay now did
we shift a paradigm
yes yeah
so yeah so if you talk about energy
drinks we shifted energy drinks are no
longer unhealthy well as far as we're
concerned ours are not unhealthy not
unhealthy actually completely healthy I
gave one to a we had a
um we're doing some improvements on our
house and the contractors came by
super nice guy
so I offered him one he was like oh man
I I love I like Energy Drinks like he
looked at he said Jocko oh I love Jocko
I was like all the good news about this
energy drink regardless how much you
love or don't love Jaco that's the case
may or may not be this energy drink is
good for you yep see I'm saying he was
reading it yeah he was down for the
cause yeah so that's good and I would
say I'm kind of good for you too like
that guy that contractor yeah I think
I'm actually pretty good for him too
yeah you know yeah yeah I'm not throwing
anything negative out there for him no
he's not listening to me thinking oh I
think I can skate on work yeah he's not
thinking oh it doesn't matter if I'm
healthy he's not thinking oh if I'm
gonna be running some other people on my
team maybe I should be an authoritarian
leader that barks or is he's not saying
any of that so I think I'm good for him
and I think my drink is good for him I
think you're correct it's not like he
came over said he loves Jocko because
you ran him into a ditch somewhere there
you go see him saying you're obviously
doing great work out here all right girl
oh that's a little bit extreme I agree I
appreciate it thank you thank you
nonetheless look no more unhealthy
energy drinks
no more uh shabby tasting energy drinks
boom got you all good all good good for
you good for performance mentally and
physically boom we got protein as well
yeah ready to drink hey look we've been
kind of um not neglecting but we haven't
been talking about the actual monk monk
the clean oh great the pow pow um
see now you know now that you're a
snowboarder yes sir you know now you
know about that pow pow all day so keep
in mind that is still a massive massive
option but yes if you're interested in
maybe saving some time uh having
improved convenient scenario with that
same good tasting yeah sometimes I just
need like something that I want to taste
something sweet and I don't want to mix
up a whole milk and have it in the
fridge and get that little RTD hitter oh
yeah they're just cool there's on the
Rocks as they say like cold yeah cold in
the fridge
the pow pow yeah that's what it's called
now by the way if you get the milk
powders henceforth only referred to as
the Mulk pow pow the that's when you're
in the mood to like really kind of
elaborate on some Gourmet milkshakes
which hey there's a time for that trust
me oh yeah boom perfect a perfect amount
of protein whatever you choose a perfect
type of protein and it tastes super
we're good so there you go to
jockoffuel.com you can get all this you
can get vitamin D3 you can join one for
krill oil super krill
Cold War just you can get the goods man
jockofill.com you can also get it at
Wawa you can get the Vitamin Shop
military commissaries Hannaford Dash
stores in Maryland wake Fern ShopRite
HEB Meyer
we were rocking in those stores hey
everybody that goes to HEB in Meyer
thank you
thank you you're just making winners and
hey if you go to these other stores
these other stores especially the
convenience stores that's a Battlefield
it's a battlefield in those convenience
stores there's big giant corporations
and you know who I'm talking about they
pay millions of dollars when they saw a
threat as soon as they saw a threat as
soon as they saw the market share
disappearing oh it wasn't disappearing
as soon as they saw Frac portions of
their market share getting pulled they
went on the offense and they got
fundamental nuclear weapons called
millions and millions and millions of
dollars so when you roll into Wawa
go and clean the shelves go let them
know what's up
let them know that
we're here
and we don't care oh you moved us down a
shelf take it out of eye level that's
the kind of stuff they do oh they do
that kind of stuff it's a battlefield
man it's deep but Wawa was great they
they brought us in there but look
they're running a business too
so if you're going to Wawa if you go
into one of these convenience stores
roll in there get some don't get tricked
into buying you know the poison you
don't want to let that happen so there
you go everyone out there when you roll
into these stores we appreciate it it's
a it's uh it makes our job easier
and it allows us to further expand
you're helping the people that don't
have the stuff available right now right
California's rough man convenience in
California is rough it's a there's a
whole thing I'd have to talk through but
there's just a lot of
disparate companies out here it's not
like one Unified
not like there's a unified chain like
this is the one the even the the ones
that you might think of off the top of
your head a lot of those are owned by
very small franchisees that only have
one or two stores and it's just we're
working on it
out here on the West Coast we're working
on it uh but everyone that's in the
midwest in Texas that you're making it
easier for everybody for us to get this
everybody so thank you thank you for
that support
and this stuff is clean man and by the
way I I forgot to tell you I forgot to
bring them but we have milk cookies
right I I just had back to back cookies
before I came here back to back and and
the first one I just had it and I was
like damn bro so they're good to go yeah
they're good to go I knew they were
gonna be good to go when Freya my oldest
daughter she sent me a text like malt
cookies I hadn't had one yet she's like
mold cookies GTG
GTG good to go so anyways I had two
before I came here the first one normal
dry we'll say the next one I straight
poured a glass of milk there's a
chocolate chip cookie bro I dipped it
like I was drinking like I was eating a
freaking whatever Toll House yeah I
understand only Toll House you got
downside oh yeah you're like oh can I
have a toll house and some type 2
diabetes please no can I yes no no my
body said no yeah then you crack open
that mold cookie
so good yeah so good and I put it I
dipped it in milk like I was in the next
level you know when you're having a I
don't want to say like an out of body
experience but when you're just when
you're like you have a paradigm shift
yeah you already brought this up so I'm
allowed to say a dorky word I had a
paradigm shift where I was like wait a
second I'm literally having a chocolate
chip cookie right now with milk by the
way and I'm completely no downside you
know I'm getting stronger as I eat a
chocolate chip cookie that's a paradigm
shift in the world right that's Nobel
Prize that's Nobel Prize right
um yep I can't refute that is it not it
is like a chocolate chip cookie with
milk I'm getting stronger smarter and
faster better more healthy it's good for
you good for you straight up so is that
not Nobel Prize I don't know who runs
that thing yeah right just talk to them
yeah at least get it out there see what
up see what up I understand and I feel
the same exact way and I'm with you with
a milk thing like there's there I think
I'm to the point in my life thankfully
where I'm gonna have one before when I
get home right now I'm having milk and
cooking you're thinking about it
well thankfully
um you know I don't have to enjoy
cookies without milk right now so milk
is a necessary part of the cookie
experience yeah so yeah small cookie
okay look if you lactose intolerant
right get the lactose free yeah there's
no problem no problem no problem still
on the path on that one and yes you get
to enjoy your milking cookies yeah it is
it
I had a it was a moment like to eat the
first one and be like wait a second and
then just break out you know he got the
uh the cups in your house that have like
a wider mouth yeah like they're bigger
yeah Sam Harris give us some good ones
did he yeah the the waking up ones
they're they're big oh yeah all day I
know because I I had literally the last
milk I had was in one of those cups
well there you go I broke out one of
those except for mine wasn't a Sam
Harris one mine said get after it I
think you might know what the one I'm
talking about so there you go milk and
milk cookies uh you can order those I
think those are only right now jungle
fuels.com so go get some of those
they're freaking outstanding and you can
you can have a cookie and get stronger
and look I'm sure someone's listening
right now that's part of the Nobel Prize
thing let me know just let me know when
when you want me to show up
the team will bring the team in because
look I don't get all the credit right no
I'm not getting the credit it's not me
no it's the team sure but as the face of
the you know the cookie maybe I get The
Nobel Prize for it sure nah I'd pass it
on to the Troops the troops are getting
it but someone deserves it all right
cool you're so humble also originusa.com
if you need jeans if you need boots if
you need a jiu jitsu gi which you do if
you're not training Jiu Jitsu you should
be
if you need haunt gear
go to originusa.com and get some
American made gear
that's what you want
you want to support
communism you don't want to support
tyranny and oppression
you wanna pay for slave labor
you don't want that to happen
you want the highest quality
[Music]
clean right now we're just getting
better all the time we're constantly
looking and improving everything that
we're doing so originusa.com get
yourself some American made everything
it's interesting because the there is
this distinct difference and it seems
obvious but maybe not from moment to
moment but when you get a pair of jeans
or whatever something that's made where
the person who physically made it the
person who designed it the person who
physically made it like put it under the
sewing machine and physically made it
when they care about every single one
that they make like I care about this
one I'm not punching the clock I'm not
surviving so I don't get whipped or
whatever right you know I I care about
this pair of jeans about this boot like
man if I if I even mess up that one I
hear about that let me redo that one so
it's perfect
the the genes that you get they're going
to be way different you know we talked
the little I kind of breezed over it but
like the Superstition thing that he
talked about like hey if you've got
people that are Superstition don't make
fun of it support it well there's some
kind of like what's the reality behind
that what is what is the reality behind
there's a little bit of a of a curse
when you get a when you get a a pair of
jeans from a sweatshop that people were
were harmed that the environment was
harmed to make you look you may not feel
that but you might and now if you put on
a pair of origin jeans you put those on
and you know that those things were made
by freedom
right and all of a sudden you know
you've done something positive for the
universe and the universe probably knows
that too that sure does
there you go man get that Karma Good
Karma Good Karma right is that a thing
yeah it's a thing I think it is yeah
Well yeah if I if I don't know you and I
give you and I'm in a bad mood and I
give you the stink eye
intuitively the chance of you giving me
the stink eye back pretty high so it
works in a nutshell
I always think of it from like a
leadership perspective I don't doubt
that at all like oh you go around
treating people bad
Karma yeah he's gonna come back and get
you yeah you go around treating the
environment bad and karma's gonna come
back you go around treating your
employees bad Karma's gonna come back
and get you that's what's gonna happen
my dad had a sing
he said he wouldn't say it all the time
but every once in a while he'd say he
would say bad things happen to bad
people so and usually under these
circumstances when you just you know
like look we all have that little evil
man inside of us even as little kids
where it's like hey you want to get over
or you want to like
it takes a lot of work to exercise the
high road or something like this right
where so you know you're gonna do the
you know you're going to seek revenge or
you're gonna you know bully your little
brother hmm
and sometimes you got to get reminded
that hey like that that short-term
gratification from your little evil deed
that you think is like harmless or
whatever in the grand scheme of things
this is what the grand scheme of thing
says bad things happen to bad people
just don't forget that BC BC has spoken
put it outward yep as we might say
nonetheless yes it's true it's it's a
very uh uh it's a thing for sure also
drop out of the store you want to
represent we're all on this path
together
you know varying places in the world
whatever but we're on the same path
varying versions of the path varying
speeds on the path but we're all on the
path if you want to represent on this
path
that's where you can get your shirts and
hoodies and teeth uh hats and whatnot
chocolate store there's a new shirt
you've been telling me about for the
short Locker shirt Locker yes yeah
should I reveal it yeah review okay so
it is a shirt here's the story behind it
typically all the shirts from this okay
there's a shirt Locker that's the
subscription scenario you get a new
shirt every month so here's the thing
and I usually just say okay the designs
are whatever I say about the designs
they're cool
but what I don't always say is all
designs have a story behind them all of
them every single one
we call them layers this one this
particular shirt is the shirt it's uh
it's pretty simple it has the you know
the logo that you know the
representative stuff but on the bottom
of the front upside down
there's a passage if you will written
says what are you doing right now
so it's upside down the bottom of your
shirt so if you're sitting down
especially yeah and you you're looking
around and you look down it's gonna that
message is gonna be loud and clear just
for you what are you doing right now
especially if you're sitting sounds like
you're watching Netflix
exactly I saw just a little reminder
some of us we like that prompt you know
it helps there you go but yeah yeah if
you want to uh check all this stuff out
you like something get something it's on
jockostore.com there you go subscribe to
the podcast subscribe to Jocko
underground.com subscribe to our YouTube
channel get psychological warfare check
out origin USA's YouTube channel check
out jungle fuels YouTube channel YouTube
channels going on flipsidecanvas.com
Dakota Meyer making cool stuff to hang
on your wall I've written a bunch of
books
a novel final spin a bunch of leadership
books a bunch of kids books
six kids books
do you know that six children's books
more common
miking the dragons all the way the
warrior kid books there you go about
face by hackworth check that book out I
wrote the forward to the new version of
it which is an honor to be able to do
that and then of course extreme
ownership in the dichotomy leadership
wrote with life Batman and I also have a
leadership consultancy we solve problems
through leadership go to aslamfront.com
for details
if you want us to come and help your
business if you want to come to one of
our Live Events check that out
we also have an online training platform
the demand signal for leadership
training is so high
we couldn't meet it so we made a online
training academy for leadership and life
go to extreme ownership.com if you want
to take ownership of your life if you
want to take ownership of your world if
you want to take ownership of your
business
we will teach you extreme ownership.com
also if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families you want to help gold
star families check out Mama lease
Mark Lee's mom mama Lee
she's got a charity organization does
Unbelievable work
go to America's Mighty Warriors dot org
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved and don't forget about heroes
and horses.org we got Micah Fink right
now no one's heard from him for 72 days
we got one satellite transponder that
said he is alive he is doing well and he
is now dressed in a mountain lion skin
and he is making progress out in the
wilderness
if you want to connect with us echo's at
Echo Charles on the social media I'm at
Jocko willink but just be advised
algorithms looking to grab you so don't
let it happen also thanks to the folks
out there in the ultimate leadership
position those in the military around
the world facing the toughest challenges
and moving forward toward those
challenges
to protect us in this world and the same
goes to our police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service and all First Responders
you all step up to face challenges every
day and Lead
so we thank you for keeping us safe and
everyone else out there
pretty early on in this book today we
covered the fact
that fear and anger and frustration and
any emotion can be diverted
from flight
to attack
and it gets diverted by you you're the
one that gets to divert it you get to
decide whether you run or whether you
fight you get decide to decide whether
you curl up in a ball or you curl your
fist to brawl
whether you surrender
or decide to go and Conquer that is your
decision
and I recommend you make the decision
to get up
and get after it
and until next time the zeko and Jocko
out